GOOD MORNING LADIES GERMAN
THAT'S GET STARTED I KNOW THAT
THAT SENATOR HAS TO GET GOING
SOON SAW ALASKA.
THE DOG HE'D START OFF FOR WHAT
SOME OPENING REMARKS.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU JUST SIMPLY WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR OUR CHAIR HAVING THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT DISCUSSION.
SIMPLICITY BELIEF BUT I MEAN
THAT THE CLOCK IS TICKING.
AND.
.
I I KNOW IT IN MY EYES MYSELF
TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE PROBABLY
IN A DAILY BASIS IF NOT TWICE A
DAY.
BECAUSE OF PRESSURES ON FROM THE
PEOPLE OF OUR COMMUNITY I THINK
THEY THEY THEY HAVE A FEELING
THAT THE GOVERNMENT'S NOT DOING
ENOUGH FOR THIS IN THIS IS THE
MESSAGE THAT I GET FROM THEM.
WHEN ARE WE GONNA START SAYING
IMPROVEMENTS ONE IS THIS PROBLEM
CAN BE SOLVED ONE WHEN I HEAR
ABOUT A SOLUTION.
AND I DON'T I DON'T BLAME THEM
THIS IS.
THIS IS THEIR THEIR THEIR HOME
DISK AT LEAST COMMUNITIES ARE
WHERE THEY CALL HOME WHERE IT. I
MEAN WHERE OF A BIG PORTION OF
THE CROPS FROM OUR STATE GET
PRODUCED.
SHIPPED ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THESE ARE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
AREA TO THE STATE AND IT JUST
SEEMS THAT.
.
THIS STATE AND THIS COUNTRY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN PARTICULAR
IS NOT GIVEN. THIS PROBLEM THE
ATTENTION IT DESERVES NEEDED
THIS ADMINISTRATION'S ATTENTIONS
FOCUSED ELSEWHERE.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES A AFFECTING.
ALL OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THIS
IF IT'S GONNA AFFECT OUR WATER
SUPPLY CAN AFFECT ENVIRONMENT.
QUALITY OF LIFE.
AND IT'S OF SOLVABLE PROBLEMS SO
EVERYBODY THAT'S BEEN PART A
SOLUTION AYE AYE.
I I THANK YOU BUT AT THE SAME
TIME I MEAN WE NEED TO PUSH THIS
AGENDA A LITTLE MORE VIGOROUSLY.
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH WITH
PRACTICABLE.
AN IMPLEMENTABLE SOLUTIONS I'M
VERY PROUD OF THE FACT THAT
PASSED LAST YEAR WE.
WE APPROVED THE TENURE
MITIGATION STRATEGY SHORT ON
FUNDS SO.
AS PART BOND IS ESSENTIAL.
BUT WE WHICH IS EVEN THEN IT
WILL NOT BE ENOUGH IT'LL BE A
FRACTION OF THE SOLUTION.
AND I I HAVE I'M ENCOURAGED THAT
OTHER THINGS ARE WE GONNA.
THE OTHER THINGS FOR WE'D WE ARE
DOING COULD BEAR MORE FRUIT.
BUT LIKE I SAID I I ASK
EVERYBODY THAT'S INVOLVED TO
PLEASE GIVE THIS THIS MATTER
EUROPE MUSCLE TENSION.
I I FEEL THAT WE ARE AND I FEEL
THAT. WE WE WE CONTINUE TO HOST.
THESE COMMITMENT COMMITTEE
MEETINGS AND THE SESSIONS AND WE
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS THIS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE. LEVEL BUT WE NEED
WE NEED THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO BE PART OF THIS.
WE EVEN MADE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
TO PUT A LITTLE MORE EFFORT INTO
THIS INTO.
COME UP WITH.
A STRATEGY YOU GOT CUT.
FINALLY GETS US TO WHEN IT WE
NEED TO GO.
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE. ARE BEING
AFFECTED EVERYDAY WHEN YOU GO
TALK TO KIDS OUT THERE WITH PASS
MOTHER CAN BARELY BREATHE.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN TELL
THEM TO ASSUAGE THEIR FEARS OR
CONCERNS THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN
TELL THEM.
SAY YOU KNOW MY BAD OR.
WE'RE WORKING ON IT ONE DAY WE
WILL SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
SO.
SIMPLY SIMPLY PUT.
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
FOR THIS HEARING AND.
.
AND I EVERYONE ELSE HERE ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S BEEN.
PART OF HELPING US.
I KNOW SOME OF THE VOTES HAVE
BEEN DIFFICULT SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE BROUGHT
FOR HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT THERE'D
THERE'D DIFFICULT TASKS.
BUT FOR OUR COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE
BEEN THAT BEEN THERE THAT HAVE
ALLOWED US TO PUT SOME OF THIS
FUNDING AND AND.
TO ADVANCEMENT OF BILLS THAT WE
WORKED ON WANT TO THANK YOU AS
WELL BECAUSE. THIS IS NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE IN OUR STATE THIS
ISSUE HAS NEVER RISEN TO THE TOP
WHERE'S BEEN TAKEN SERIOUSLY AS
A HOUSE IN LAST FEW YEARS.
AND AND I THINK THE GOVERNOR AND
THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE'S
STRAIGHT SPECIALLY THOSE THAT
HAVE HAD THE COURAGE TO.
TO GIVE US A A A VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF SOLVING THIS PROBLEM THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SIR
HUESO AYE I DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
YOU WEEKS LEADING UP TO THE.
S. B. FIVE PARK BOND VOTE.
SENATOR NOW I GOT TO MEET WITH
THE GOVERNOR AND TO KIND OF
FORCED TO HAND A BIT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE WAS A. REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION. FOR THE A WATER
IMPORT A COMPONENT TO A
POSSIBLE.
CHAUNCEY SOLUTION SOME THAT HAD
NOT BEEN PART OF THE PLAN ITSELF
SONIC KNOWLEDGE UNIT YOUR
PERSISTENCE ON THAT I THINK. IS
WHAT THAT MADE AT THE AGENCY
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION AND. NOW
WE HAVE A HANDFUL OF.
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED.
TO THE AGENCY. SO I THINK YOU
AGAIN LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING
EVERYONE WAS HERE OF LONG WITH
MY COLLEAGUES. ARE FROM THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE THING SO MUCH FOR THAT
LET ME SOME OF YOUR TIME ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT'S.
IMPORTANT AS A CENTER SAID TO
THE STATE. AB BUT THAT THAT WE
HEAR CONSTANTLY IN OUR DISTRICT
GOT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THE SOLVENCY ISSUE IS ONE THAT
GOES BACK MANY YEARS BUT FOR THE
FIRST TIME. WE HAVE A TEN YEAR
PLAN THAT IS IN PLACE TO ADDRESS
BOTH THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
ASPECTS OF THIS PROBLEM AS WELL
AS THE ECOLOGICAL CHALLENGES
THAT EXIST THERE.
WE KNOW THAT THEIR BEEN
TREMENDOUS BARRIERS TO MOVING
THE AGENDA FORWARD. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME.
WE NOW RUN INTO A HANDFUL OF
DELAYS AND PART OF OUR
CONVERSATION TODAY.
IS THAT WE WANT TO HEAR WHAT
CAN WE DO AS POLICY MAKERS TO
FACILITATE UP AN EXPEDITIOUS A
PLAN. MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
MINIMAL AMOUNT OF DELAYS AS
POSSIBLE CONSIDERING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE HAVE. IN
THE COMMUNITY. BUT THIS WON'T BE
OUR LAST HEARING OF COURSE.
OUR PLAN IS TO HAVE. A
ADDITIONAL HEARING AND WE INVITE
BOTH OUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
A TO JOIN US IN THE BEAUTIFUL
SUMMER TIME IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY.
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION AS A
FOLLOW UP
THE TODAY'S.
DISCUSSION AND SEE WHAT TYPE OF
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE SINCE TODAY.
ARM WHEN WE'D MEET SOMETIME IN
THE SUMMER. SO WITH THAT I THINK
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT WE GET
STARTED MISS RACHEL ELDERS FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WILL GIVE US. A BRIEF OVERVIEW
AND WOOD THEN JUMP RIGHT INTO
THE TWO PANELS THAT WE HAVE HERE
POP FOR THE REST OF THE HEARINGS
OF. GOOD MORNING WELCOME AND YOU
MAY BEGIN GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BEARS RACHEL
EHLERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND I THINK MY
MATH SERGEANTS HIM THAT PASSING
A HAND OUT THAT WE'VE PREPARED.
I THINK MY ROLE TODAY IS TO
PROVIDE SOME VERY BRIEF CONTEXT
OCCUPY BACKGROUND EXTREMELY
BRIEF GIVEN THAT I THINK THE
MEMBERS ARE PRETTY FAMILIAR WITH
THE ISSUE. SPEND A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME ON THE FISCAL AND THEN GET
OUT OF YOUR WAY FOR YOU TO GET
INTO THE MEAT OF THE HEARING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION PANEL.
FOLLOWING ME AND
AND STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL.
SO TURNING TO PAGE ONE. FAT
DISPIRITO REVIEW OF THE SEE IT
IS THE LARGEST LAKE IN TERMS OF
SURFACE AREA IN THE STATE
EXTREMELY SALINE BECAUSE IT HAS
NO OUTLET. SO AS THE SALTY WATER
COMES IN FROM AGRICULTURAL
RUNOFF IT HAS NOWHERE TO GO AND
OF AS IT EVAPORATES THE SALTS
ARE LEFT BEHIND. THE LAKE IS
SHRINKING WHICH IS ONE OF THE
ISSUES WE'RE HERE TO DISCUSS.
M. IT BEEN PART BECAUSE IT HAS
NO OUTLET AND IN PART BECAUSE OF
THAT SOME WATER TRANSFER DEALS
IN PARTICULAR THE QUANTIFICATION
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT KNOWN AS
THE QSAR IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE. WHICH TRANSFERRED SOME
WATER FROM AGRICULTURAL USE TO
OTHER AREAS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REDUCING THE RUN OFF
INTO THE LAKE THAT HAS BEEN
MITIGATION WATER BEING PROVIDED
OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS BUT
THAT OUT REQUIREMENT ENDED IN
DECEMBER SO THAT'S REALLY NOT
CHANGING THE STATE OF THE LAKE
RAPIDLY NOW.
AS THE LAKE SHRINKS DRY LAKE BED
WHICH IS REFERRED TO AS PLAYA IS
EXPOSED TO NOT CREATE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT TODAY.
DOWN AT THE AT THE BOTTOM
BULLET YOU CAN SEE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ESTIMATED
THAT ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED ACRES OF PLAYA ANNUALLY
WILL BE EXPOSED OVER THE NEXT.
TEN YEARS IT VARIES YEAR BY YEAR
BUT THAT'S THE AVERAGE ESTIMATE.
SO TURNING TO PAGE TWO.
WHY DOES THIS MATTER WHY IS THIS
A STATEWIDE ISSUE SEVERAL
REASONS?
pRISKS THAT PRESENT THEM IN THE
REGION.
HAS THE LAKE SHRINKS AND DIE
PLAYA IS EXPOSED PARTICULATE
MATTER ABOUT BECOMES AIRBORNE
CREATING RISKS BOTH FOR HUMANS
AS WELL AS WILDLIFE AND
AGRICULTURAL.
INTERESTS
IT'S ALSO AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT MIGRATORY BIRD HABITAT
HAS OTHER WETLANDS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE BEEN.
FILLED IN AND AND.
DRIED UP AND DEVELOPED OVER THE
YEARS THIS IS ONE OF THE.
.
IMPORTANT HABITATS THAT STILL
IS AVAILABLE ON THE PACIFIC
FLYWAY AS BIRDS TRAVEL FROM
NORTH TO SOUTH AND SOUTH TO
NORTH.
I IT SO IT'S NOT ONLY IMPORTANT
FOR THESE BIRDS AT THAT THERE IS
WATER THERE BUT ALSO THAT THE
WATER'S NOT.
SALINE TO SUPPORT THE FISH THAT
THEY NEED TO EAT.
THERE'S ALSO HABITAT FOR A FOR
AT RISK ROBERTSON SPECIES THAT
HAVE BEEN LISTED BOTH ON THE
FEDERAL AND STATE ENDANGERED
SPECIES LISTS.
AYE THIS IS ALSO A KEY COMPONENT
OF ALL OF THE STATE'S WATER
AGREEMENTS ON THE ALONG THE
COLORADO RIVER.
BOTH IN THE PAST AND SOME OF THE
FUTURE I DROUGHT CONTINGENCY
NEGOTIATIONS THAT ARE
UNDERGOING.
AND THEN FINALLY IT IS HAS A
GREAT DEAL OF REGIONAL
IMPORTANCE FOR THE ECONOMY
HOUSING MARKET AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTIVITY. A QUALITY OF LIFE
AND ALSO RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO TURNING TO PAGE THREE THE
STATE HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
THIS REGION THE STATE HAS
COMMITTED TO MITIGATING THE
EFFECTS OF THIS WATER TRANSFERS
AND PAYING MOST OF THE COSTS
ABOVE THE LEVEL THAT WAS SET
WITH THE OTHER.
ACCU ESSAY PARTIES THERE WAS
ALSO RAM THIS WAS AGAIN
MEMORIALIZED IN A RECENT M. O.
U. WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THE STATE WAS GONNA PLAY
THE LEAD ROLE.
SO AS YOU WILL DISCUSS IN THE
MEAT OF YOUR AGENDA TODAY THE
CITY HAS PREPARED IS BEGINNING
TO IMPLEMENT A MANAGEMENT PLAN.
THAT I REFERRED TO AS THE SALTON
SEA MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AS SMP
PHASE ONE HAS WAS ADOPTED IN THE
PLAN LAST MARCH THAT SAID ANNUAL
MILESTONES FOR HOW MUCH ADAM OF
THE EXPOS PLAYER WAS GOING TO BE
MITIGATED. BOTH FOR HABITAT AS
WELL AS FOR DUST SUPPRESSION.
AND THAT PLAN INCLUDED A GOAL OF
CONSTRUCTING FIVE HUNDRED ACRES
OF PROJECTS IN THIS YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SO THAT'S
PROBABLY ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
YOU MAY WANT TO ASK THE NEXT
PANELIST HOW IS THAT PLAN GOING.
AND THEN GOALS OF HAVE NEARLY
THIRTY THOUSAND ACRES BY THE END
OF THE TEN YEAR PLAN THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
HAS ALSO BEEN INVOLVED RECENTLY
ANOTHER SOME INFORMATION IN YOUR
PACKET ABOUT AND.
THAT THEY ADOPTED IN ORDER THAT
THAT PUT THOSE ANNUAL GOALS FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS AND
MITIGATION PROJECTS.
IN THE ORDER SO THERE THEY ARE
ALSO A PLAYER INVOLVED IN TRYING
TO HELP ENSURE THAT THE SCHOOLS
ARE UNDERTAKEN.
SO TURNING TO PAGE FOUR I THINK
THIS IS THE HEART OF WHAT I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO PRESENT FOR YOU
TODAY.
THIS SUMMARIZES THE FUNDING
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED THUS FAR
FOR ACTIVITIES AT THE CITY. YOU
CAN SEE IN THE LEFT HAND COLUMN
THAT AMOUNT THAT'S AUTHORIZED
AND THAT IN THE RIGHT HAND
COLUMN ARE RIGHT MIDDLE COLUMN
THE AMOUNT THAT STILL REMAINING.
THERE'S BEEN FUNDING FROM THREE
BONDS PROVIDED.
.
GO SEE PROPOSITION ONE IS NOT ON
YOUR TALK ABOUT THAT A MINUTE
BUT THE SO THIS IS FUNDING THAT.
HAS BEEN PROVIDED OVER THE PAST.
I'M.
SEVERAL DECADES AT THIS POINT.
A MOST OF IT'S BEEN USED FOR
PLANNING EFFORTS THERE HAS BEEN
SOME INITIAL CONSTRUCTION OF
SOME PROJECTS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
DESCRIPTION. THERE'S BEEN
FUNDING FROM THE STATE A SMALL
AMOUNT PROVIDED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOT MUCH.
AND THEN FUNDING FROM LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT WERE PARTY TO THE
QSAR THE FIRST LINE THAT SAYS Q.
ESSAY AT AT THE IN THE LOCAL
RATTO CHRIS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY YOU CONCEDE THAT TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION
COMMITMENT.
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND THREE THE
THE THREE AGENCIES HOTEL WATER
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IMPAIR
THEIR KITCHEN DISTRICT IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY. AT
COMMITTED TO PROVIDE A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
MILLION WITH INFLATION OVER TIME
THAT THAT CURRENT ESTIMATE IS
THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE AN
EQUIVALENT OF TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT.
I AM SOME OF THAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED THUS FAR TO START SOME
PROJECTS AND AND REALLY TO
SUPPORT THE MITIGATION WATER
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED OVER THE
PAST FIFTEEN YEARS BUT THEIR
STUFF FUNDING. FOR THOSE LOCAL
EFFORTS.
AVAILABLE THERE.
SO.
YOU KNOW I THINK IN SUMMARY
QUITE A BIT OF MONEY AUTHORIZED
ABOUT HALF OF IT SPENT. BAT NAM.
NEWTON NOT A HUGE AMOUNT OF
ACTIVITY ACTUALLY. GOING ON AND
ON THE GROUND BUT THAT THE LAKE
HASN'T SHRUNK AT TO THE DEGREE
THAT IT'S GOING TO START NOW
SELF
AND ALL OF THIS FUNDING AND BOTH
THAT HAS BEEN AUTHORIZED AND
THEN SPENT IS PRIOR TO THE TEN
YEAR PLAN.
AND FOR EFFORTS NOT ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TENURE PLAN.
SO THAT LEADS TO THE QUESTION OF
WHAT HOW WE CAN IMPLEMENT THE
TEN YEAR PLAN AND THE PROJECTS
THERE.
SO TURNING TO PAGE FIVE.
M..
THE FIRST BULLET JUST ADDRESSES
THAT FIGURE THAT FOR ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION HAS BEEN
AUTHORIZED THAT'S FAR. THE PLAN
ESTABLISHES TENURE GOALS AND
ASSOCIATED COSTS OF ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION SEPARATE AGAIN
FROM THE FUNDING SHOWN IN THE
TABLE HERE.
SO HOW WE GONNA PAY FOR THAT
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION WELL
PROPOSITION ONE PROVIDED EIGHTY
MILLION THAT'S AVAILABLE IT'S
ALREADY BEEN A BAD APPROVED BY
VOTERS AND.
A PERMITTED BY THE LEGISLATURE'S
THAT'S AVAILABLE. TIME AND I
THINK YOU'LL HEAR FROM FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION HOW THEY'RE
PLANNING TO USE THAT FUNDING.
SO THAT'S OF THAT'S AVAILABLE
FOR THESE TENURE GOALS. BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE REST WELL. PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT AS WAS NOTED WOULD
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IF APPROVED BY
VOTERS IN JUNE.
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL BALLOT
MEASURE THAT DISQUALIFIED FOR
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AN EIGHT POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLAR WATER AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BONTA THAT WOULD PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IF VOTERS APPROVE FAT.
SO THAT GET THAT WOULD GET
CLOSE.
BUT THAT'S.
ONLY FOR THOSE FIRST TEN YEARS
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THOSE TEN
YEARS AND ALSO WHAT WHAT ABOUT
THE MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
FOR THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
CONSTRUCTED HOW WILL THAT BE
FINE AND I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER.
CROWD GOOD GOOD QUESTION YOU MAY
WANT TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION
I'M NOT SURE AT THIS POINT. THAT
THERE'S AN ANSWER FOR THAT THAT
THAT FUNDING SPEND FOR ADAM.
IDENTIFIED AT THIS POINT.
SO WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR. THEM
THANK YOU FOR THAT ONE REVIEW
ANY CA COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
ON THE.
LEO REPORT IT SIR.
YEAH JUST ON THE PLANET.
GRAPH THEIR WHERE CHINA AND
SPENT.
WHAT WHY IS YOU KNOW IT AT THIS
POINT WHY HAS IT BEEN?
FUND'S SPENT OF THAT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION THAT. WAS
AUTHORIZED.
SO IN AND MOVING DOWN THROUGH
THE CATEGORIES I THINK WHEN YOU
LOOK AT SOME OF THE BIGGEST POTS
OF UNSPENT FUNDING YOU SEE THE
PROPOSITION EIGHTY FOUR THERE'S
TWENTY THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
AS THE BULK OF THAT HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATED. AWARDED BY THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD IS
READY TO GET GOING AND HIT THE
GROUND SO THE PROJECT IS JUST
TAKEN AWHILE TO GET.
GOING I GUESS PLANNED IN READY
BUT BUT THAT MONEY IS
ESSENTIALLY COMMITTED AND READY
TO TO HIT THE GROUND. THE OTHER
BIG POTS OF FUNDING DAD THAT US
A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY FUNDING
IN THE SONGS HE RESTORATION
LIMIT HAVE BEEN PLANNED TO BE
PAID IN OVERTIME BY THOSE
AGENCIES. SO IT'S BEEN COMMITTED
BUT IT ISN'T REALLY AN HAND
THAT'S CAN BE PAID AND ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS.
IN TERMS OF SOME OF THAT THE
FEDERAL GRANTS I THINK I HAVE
JUST BEEN RECEIVED SO.
FROM MY DAY AGAIN GOOD QUESTIONS
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT'S TAKEN
AWHILE TO GET THE PLANS.
THE PERMITS TO GET THE PROJECTS
READY BUT MOST OF THIS MONEY AT
THIS POINT THEY'RE READY TO
SPEND.
YES
SCORE.
FAMOUS CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION KIND WELL FOR
THE SAME GRAPH WITH REGARD TO
THE FEDERAL EXPENDITURES OR OR
APPROPRIATIONS. IN THE
RELATIVELY SMALL OF ALL THINGS
CONSERVE IT LIKE MAYBE TWO
PERCENT OF THE OVERALL
ALLOCATION.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON WHY THAT IS
YOU MAY. IT'S BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE FROM FEDERAL.
ASSISTANCE HAS BEEN SOUGHT
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND THEN
NOTING THAT.
YOU'D THE LAST BULLET POINT IS
THAT YOU CONSIDER THAT THE STATE
IS CONSIDERING PURSUING
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING HOW
LIKELY IS THAT GIVEN HOW SMALL
AMOUNT HAS BEEN GIVEN TODAY.
YEAH I THINK THOSE ARE GREAT
QUESTIONS IN AND I'M I'M HOPING
HOPEFULLY LAST THE
ADMINISTRATION AND SEE WHAT
THEIR RESPONSES TO AND I THINK.
CERTAINLY FROM A STATE
PERSPECTIVE IT'S DISAPPOINTING
THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD MORE FEDERAL
SUPPORT IF YOU LOOK AT THINK IN
YOUR PACKET YOU'VE GOT A GRAPH
THAT SHOWS THAT OWNERSHIP. OF
THE SEA AND YOU CAN SEE QUITE A
BIT OF IT IS FEDERALLY OWNED SO
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY'VE GOT A A
PRETTY STRONG STAKE IN THIS AS
WELL. HAVEN'T COME FORTH WITH
THE DOLLARS YET. TIME
THE IT SEEMS IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
NOT ONLY SHOULD THEY.
BE INTERESTED GIVEN THAT THE
OWNERSHIP THERE'S ALSO PROBABLY
SOME SOME LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY
THEY'RE GIVEN THEIR OWNERSHIP
AND THAT THEN THE POTENTIAL
LIABILITY OF.
.
OF WHAT HAPPENS AS THE AS THE
LEAD SHRINKS.
THE STATE HAS COMMITTED TO BE.
TAKE THE LEAD ROLE. THAT THAT
THAT IS.
HOW THE STATE CHOSE TO APPROACH
IT BUT IT DOES SEEM LIKE THERE'S
THERE'S ROOM FOR FEDERAL ROLE
HERE'S FROM? THE KIDS.
THANK YOU WAS GREAT THAT HE ONE
OF THE PRISONERS MIGHT BE ABLE
TO SHED SOME LIGHT.
ON THE.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S COMPONENT
TO A TO ALL THIS IN SOME OF THE
EFFORTS THAT ARE UNDERWAY AS WE
SPEAK. DARNED THE OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MYSELF THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR OVERVIEW WILL
ASK THE. PANEL TO A PRISONER
SCOTT WILSON TED FRANK AND BRUCE
WILCOX.
THAT'S PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND MISTER WILSON IS WITH ITS
OWN SEE PROGRAM MANAGER.
I LOVE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
TED FRANK IS A BRANCH CHIEF
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION
ENHANCEMENT DIVISION. GOV ON
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
AND BRUCE WILCOX'S USES THE
SECRETARY.
SONGS HE POLICY.
FOR CALIFORNIA NATURISTS ARSES
AGENCY WELCOME JIM.
WHAT TAKE YOU IN THAT THE SAME
ORDER THAT YOU WERE LISTED?
ON THE AGENDA.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MAYBE.
FOR.
YEAH I THINK THAT PUTS ME FIRST.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR GARCIA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SCOTT WILSON AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THE THE PRIMARY ROLES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
RELATED TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SALTON SEA MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM. ARE TO PROVIDE INPUT
INTO THE HABITAT DESIGN PROCESS
SO THE PROJECTS ARE DEVELOPED TO
PROVIDE A MOSAIC FISH AND
WILDLIFE HABITAT.
ASSIST WITH THE PERMITTING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
MINIMIZATION MEASURES DURING
PROJECT CONSTRUCTION.
AND TO MANAGE THE HABITAT AND
SPECIES MONITORING ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM FOR THE
CONSTRUCTIVE HABITATS.
WE PROVIDE EXPERTISE ON HABITAT
FEATURES SUCH AS STRUCTURES FOR
BIRD NESTING AND ROOSTING AND
RANGE UPON DEPTHS FOR USE BY A
VARIETY. OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
SPECIES.
IN CONSULTATION WITH OTHER
SCIENTISTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE DEVELOP AND
MANAGE MISSION WHILE LIKE
MONITORING EFFORTS.
TO ASSESS THE FUNCTIONS OF THE
CREATED HABITAT.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
WILDLIFE ENGAGES IN THE SALTON
SEA MANAGEMENT PROGRAM WITH
PERSONNEL FROM OUR SACRAMENTO
HEADQUARTERS LED BY DIRECTOR
CHUCK BOTTOM IN OUR EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP TEAM. AND LOCALLY IN
OUR INLAND DESERT REGION LED BY
REGIONAL MANAGER LESLIE MCNAIR.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE SOLVENCY PROGRAM IS
BASED IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
JUST NORTH OF THE SALTON SEA.
ABOUT THE PROGRAM MANAGER AND A
TEAM OF SCIENTISTS COORDINATE
PLAN.
AND IMPLEMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION ACTIONS AT THE
PSALMS.
I'M THE FORMER SOLVENCY PROGRAM
MANAGER CURRENTLY THE
CONSERVATION PLANNING MANAGER
FOR INLAND DESERT'S REGION.
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE HAS
ADVERTISED THE SALTON SEA
PROGRAM MANAGER POSITION IN
MARCH AND APRIL AND IS WORKING
TO COMPLETE THE HIRING PROCESS.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH SECRETARY
ASSISTANT SECRETARY WILCOX
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES.
THAT LEAD THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
SCIENTISTS TEAM.
ACCORDING IT WITH OTHER AGENCIES
SCIENTISTS AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPLEMENT
PROJECTS AT THE SALTON SEA
DURING THE HIRING PROCESS.
SO SPECIFIC TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE SALTON SEA PROJECTS.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE HAS.
PROVIDED GUIDANCE ON THE HABITAT
DESIGN ELEMENTS.
THAT WE ENGAGE IN ONGOING
PLANNING AND CONSULTATIONS WITH
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
CURIEL IRRIGATION DISTRICT
SALTON SEA AUTHORITY. AND OTHER
AGENCIES AND SCIENTISTS TO BRING
THE PROJECTS TO CONSTRUCTION.
WE ARE CONDUCTING FISH AND
WILDLIFE SURVEYS AND SAMPLING
FOR PROPOSED PROJECTS.
WE WILL ASSIST WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION MEASURES DURING THE
INITIAL SITE WORK.
SUCH AS MEASURES TO AVOID
IMPACTS TO NESTING BIRDS AND
MANAGE FOR THE ENDANGERED DESERT
PUPFISH.
IT WILL MANAGE THE MONITORING
EFFORTS DURING PROJECT
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATIONS.
DEPARTMENT FISH WILDLIFE
CONTINUES
COORDINATING WITH THE ADVISORY
SCIENCE COMMITTEE.
TO REFINE THE HABITAT DESIGN
CRITERIA AND BUILD UPON THE
MONITORING AND ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT PLAN. THAT WAS
DEVELOPED FOR THE SPECIES
CONSERVATION HABITAT PROJECT. TO
PRODUCE A MONITORING APPROACH
THAT COULD BE APPLICABLES TO ALL
OF THE SALTON SEA MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM PROJECTS.
FOR THE PHASE ONE TEN YEAR PLAN.
BOB THE SPECIES HABITAT
CONSERVATION PROJECT IT WAS
DESIGNED TO BE A PROOF OF
CONCEPT.
RECOGNIZING THE PROJECTS OF
SIMILAR SCALE AND PURPOSEHAD
NOT BEEN CONSTRUCTED OF THE.
RELATED TO FISH AND WILDLIFE
OUTCOMES.
SUCH AS FACTORS AFFECTING FISH
SURVIVAL AND HABITAT USED BY
VARIOUS BIRD SPEAKS.
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE INITIAL
PROJECTS.
AND MONITORING OF THE
CONSTRUCTED HABITATS IS
ESSENTIAL TO INFORM OUR
SCIENTIFIC UNDERSTANDING.
OF HOW THESE HABITATS WILL
FUNCTION.
AND WHAT CHANGES MAYBE NEEDED IN
FUTURE PROJECTS.
FOR INCREASE THE BENEFITS TO
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL THE
AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE
THAT THE HABITAT PROJECTS ARE
CONSTRUCTED.
TO MONITOR THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
RESOURCES
AND TO LEARN AND TO ADVISE
FUTURE PROJECT DESIGN AND
OPERATIONS.
AND TO ACHIEVE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE HABITAT OUTCOMES FOR
FISH AND WILDLIFE DEPENDENT ON
THE SALTON SEA ECOSYSTEM.
RIGHT BRUCELLA GO AHEAD AND
BUILD WRAP UP I GUESS SO.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN GARCIA MY NAME'S TED
FRANK WHO MEMBERS. NOT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES.
.
YOU SHOULD HAVE A PACKET THE
HANDOUTS. THAT'LL. WALK THROUGH
AND WE HAVE ASSOCIATED LARGER
PANEL.
WHICH WERE SET UP TO BE.
AVAILABLE YOU SEE FROM THE
PUBLIC FOR YOURSELVES BUT WE'RE
FACING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION
BUT I SEE CAMERA OVER THERE SO
MAYBE THIS'LL HELP.
ON THAT SO WE'LL JUST FOLLOW
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE HANDOUTS.
NUMBER.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A. BRIEF
OVERVIEW. OF THE SALTON SEA
THERE IS ARE COLLARED IN THIS IN
THIS AREA ARE OUR FOCUS AREAS.
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF OF THE
MITIGATION FOR HABITAT OR
QUALITY. OF TREATMENTS THAT THE
STATE HAS. COMMITTED TO IT FROM
THE QUEUE I SAY.
.
THESE ARE AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN.
DEEMS TO BE THE AREAS THAT WILL
EXPOSE THE MOST PLAYA OVER TIME
AS THE CITY IS EXPECTED TO
RECEDE SO THE USER.
AREAS FOR THE NORTH AND THE
SOUTH.
AND THE AREAS THAT ARE FED BY
THE MAJOR RIVER SYSTEMS THAT
COME INTO THE SEA FILM.
.
THAT IS AREAS THAT WILL BE
FOCUSING ON.
I'M GONNA BE ON MY OWN AND A
WHITE AGAIN.
RIGHT EITHER.
THESE ARE THE FOCUSED AREAS OF
OF THE EFFORTS NO BETWEEN OUR
AGENCIES AND THEM.
WAVE RANDOMLY NUMBERED THEM BUT
THE THAT'S ROUGHLY THE PROGRESS
OF OF PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION AT THE STATE.
WILL BE FOLLOWING.
.
AND THE SOUTH END OF THE CITY
AROUND THE.
.
ALAMO NEW RIVER ARE OUR FIRST
AND A FOCUS AREAS AND I WAVE A
JUST INITIATED. HOSSAM EFFORTS
AT THE NORTH END OF SEE WITH
SOME CO THORNY AROUND THE WHITE
RIVER.
.
SO THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES IS.
BE CONSTRUCTION ARM OF THE
STATE SO OUR ROOM ROLLER
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE EFFORT IS
THE.
HOPE AND DO THE DESIGN OF
PLANNING. AND THEN FINALLY GO
INTO A CONSTRUCTION.
HIRING PELICAN CONSULTING OR OR
ENGINEERING FIRMS TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT WHATEVER ACTIONS WE AS
A GROUP.
DESIGNING COME UP WITH IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH.
NOT PART OF FISH WILDLIFE AND US
FISH WILDLIFE SERVICE AND AND
OUR PARTNERS THAT THE FEDERAL
AGENCY LEVEL.
HOME.
WELL PHILIP DIVE INTO SOME
DETAIL HERE.
.
FOR EXAMPLE SOME OF THE DESIGN
WORK THAT WE'VE. BEEN WORKING
ON.
.
ON ON A VERY FOCUSED LEVEL HAS
BEEN AN AREA IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THE CITY NEAR THE NEW
RIVER.
I'M AND THESE OUR.
THE AREA THAT WE AT THE STATE
DATA. ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
STATEMENT AND REPORT TO THE
JOINT DOCUMENT.
FOR WHAT WAS THE IN THIS
SPECIES CONSERVATION HOW WITHOUT
NOSE UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE AS
YOU HEARD FROM SCOTT.
.
AND SO OUR ROLE IS TO BE ABLE TO
WORK THROUGH THE DESIGN ASPECTS
OF WHAT WOULD THE PAWNS AND
HABITAT AREAS LOOK LIKE.
AND WHERE WERE THEY MOST LIKELY
BE.
.
SCOTT ALSO REFERRED TO THIS
BEING A PILOT PROJECT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE AT ONE.
AM ANYBODY ELSE'S NOT.
ATTEMPTED TO BUILD ON ON THE
PLAYA OF THE CITY.
SO THIS IS A BIG LEARNING CURVE
FOR FOR THE STATE EVERYBODY ELSE
NAM. THE SCA AGE WAS THE PILOT
PROJECT WE'RE GOING TO BE A
PILOT PROJECT SO THE FIRST AREA
THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY. FOCUS THEN
IS THIS.
AREA JUST TO THE EAST OF THE
NEW RIVER.
TOM LET.
LABEL THE THE NEW RIVER EAST
RIGHT NOW A MESSY AGE.
THIS IS GONNA BE SIX HUNDRED
FORTY ACRES OF THE CURRENTLY.
IS PLANNED DOUBTS WE.
.
WORKED WITH DUCKS UNLIMITED AND
FOLKS.
AVENGER OTHER ENGINEERING
EXPERTISE THAT HAVE BUILT.
WHAT ONES SIMILAR TO THIS BEFORE
SO?
WE DIDN'T PRETEND TO KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS WE WANTED
TO REACH OUT AND GET THE
EXPERTISE THAT WAS ALREADY. A
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE STATE SO
WE.
HAVE UTILIZED.
ENGINEERS FROM THE DUCKS
UNLIMITED GROUP TO HELP ADVISE
AND AND COME UP WITH PLANS AND
THEN. OUR DIVISION OF
ENGINEERING.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
ARE THE ENGINEERS THAT HAVE
REFINED AND BROUGHT THE INITIAL
DESIGNS INTO THIS COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE. REQUIREMENTS AFTER
CONTRACTING PURPOSES.
AND SO WE EXPECT THIS.
AT THE FIRST STAGE AS THE AGE
SIX HUNDRED FORTY ACRES THAT'S
THE POINT TO BE OUR FIRST
PROJECT.
ON THE GROUND.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
WITH THOSE LANDOWNERS WHICH IS
I. ID IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
AND OUR LEGAL OFFICE AND ID'S
LEGAL OFFICE HAVE BEEN WORKING.
HARD TO COME UP WITH AN EASEMENT
AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN OUR TWO.
AGENCIES SO THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
TO THE PROPERTY AND BE ABLE TO
CONSTRUCT.
THE WORK ON THEIR IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ID SO.
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
GETTING THAT STARTED.
RIGHT NOW WERE.
EXPECTING.
SOMEWHERE AROUND DECEMBER OF
THIS YEAR.
TO IMPLEMENT THAT FIRST.
CONSTRUCTION ACTION.
SO.
THAT'S.
WILL BE COMING UP. IN JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL.
THE THING ABOUT.
SO.
THIS LOCATION.
IS
S. B. SIX CONSERVATION SIX
HUNDRED FORTY ACRE PROJECT THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
THE OTHER. PARTS OF THIS PROJECT
AS YOU CAN SEE WE'VE ALREADY
THOUGHT INTO THE FUTURE HAS THAT
CEOS RECEDING WHERE ELSE ARE WE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO.
I'M.
BUILD THE NEXT PLOT LINES AND OR
WHAT AND HABITAT.
AND NOT DRY MITIGATION SO AIR.
QUALITY DUST MITIGATION ASPECT.
I KNOW THEY HAVEN'T A STIPULATED
ORDER FROM THE STATE WATER
BOARD.
WE HAVE.
ANNUAL OBLIGATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN LAID OUT.
OF THOSE ANNUAL OBLIGATIONS UP
TO FIFTY PERCENT OR WITH NO LESS
THAN FIFTY PERCENT HOUSE TO BE.
HABITAT OF AQUATIC HABITAT OF
SORT. BEYOND THAT OR ANYTHING
AFTER THAT CAN ALSO BE DRY
MITIGATION.
SO. YOU'LL SEE A MOSAIC HERE
WHERE WE'RE CURRENTLY THINKING
AREAS THAT. POTENTIALLY WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FORUM DRIVE
MEDICATION.
AS WELL AS.
PLUMMET AREAS THAT WOULD.
WORK THEIR WAY DOWN PLAN AS THE
C. RECEDES.
NAM.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO A
CONTINUING PLANNING ON THOSE
OTHER AREAS BEYOND THE SIX FOR
SIX HUNDRED FORTY ACRES.
WHICH WILL LEAD US TOWARDS THAT
TIME.
ANNUAL TARGETS STIPULATED IN THE
IN THE AGREEMENT FROM THE WATER
BOARD.
.
THERE IS ONE MORE DESIGN AT ALL.
THAT IS NOT IN YOUR HANDOUT BUT
ALL.
I'LL PUT UP A BOARD.
FOR REFERENCE.
THINGS.
ONE OF THE OTHER PROJECTS THAT
WE'VE BEEN.
.
UGH WORKING ON WITH ID AND A
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT
GROUP.
REFERRED REFERRED TO A CITY ARE.
THEY HAVE.
LEASEPLAN FROM MY AB OVER THIS
PART OF THE PROPERTY THIS IS
ACTUALLY.
.
OR MAYBE AT THE ALCOTT WELL AS
WELL AND PROJECT ITS ON THE NEW
RIVER.
AND THE IDEA THERE IS AGAIN
COMING UP WITH.
PONDING AREA THAT'S WILL
CREATES WETLAND HABITAT
PROTECTING AND A COUPLE OF THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES. OF CATFISH
AND.
THE RAIL THE CALIFORNIA RAIL.
THAT OCCUPY THAT SPACE.
WORKING WITH IDEA THEY HAVE
THEM OBLIGATIONS WHILE FOR BUT
FISH NOT PROTECTIONS AND SO
WERE.
WORKING WITH THEM TO DESIGN AN
AREA WHERE THEY ARE OBLIGATED TO
CONNECT DRAINS THAT HAVE PUT
FISH POPULATIONS IN. M. AND THAT
FEATURE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
DRINK CONNECTION SYSTEM IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT.
.
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE'RE ALSO
OBLIGATED TO DO IS NOT PRECLUDE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES IN THE AREA SO WHAT
WERE. WORKING WITH THE
GEOTHERMAL GROUP IS IS TO FIND
OUT WHAT AREAS THEY. I'D NEED OR
DESIRE TO HAVE ACCESS TO IN
ORDER TO EXPLORE.
AND DEVELOP GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES IN THIS VICINITY SO
THAT'S PARTLY.
DEFINING THE BOUNDARIES OF WHAT
THIS PROPERTY AND OUR OUR
HABITAT FEATURE MY LOOK LIKE
HERE.
SO THAT'S BEEN A GOOD
PARTNERSHIP IT'S MORE WORKING
THROUGH THE DETAILS IN THE
DESIGN LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE
THE DOUBLES ARE IN THE DETAILS.
BUT THEM THAT'S GOING GOING
WELL.
AND WE EXPECT THAT.
.
TO BE ACTUALLY OUR FIRST PROJECT
UNDER A DIFFERENT.
CONTRACTING PROCESS.
AND THAT'S A THERE'S A DETAIL
THERE THE. THE LEGISLATURE HERE
AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT A NEW.
AUTHORITY DID TO CONSTRUCT
WHICH IS CALLED DESIGN BUILD
AUTHORITY.
PREVIOUSLY THE APARTMENT IS ONLY
HAD DESIGNED BID BUILD. WHERE WE
HAVE TO COME UP WITH A HUNDRED
PERCENT DESIGN FEET FEATURES
BEFORE WE CAN GO OUT THE
CONTRACT?
UNDER NE FISHING GAME CODE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THE AUTHORITY. NOT
CALL DESIGN BUILD WHICH WILL
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT TO GO INTO
A CONTRACT WITH THE DESIGN.
INSTRUCTION FIRM AND WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP.
TO DEVELOP DESIGNS AND IMPLEMENT
AS THOSE DESIGNS ARE COMPLETED.
SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
WORK THROUGH THAT NEW PROCESS
AND COME UP WITH A MORE
EFFICIENT WAY TO GET OUT THE
CONTRACT.
UPPER PROJECTS.
SO DOT IS ONE WAY THAT THE
STATE IS SEEN TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE.
CONSTRUCTION HAPPEN A LITTLE
FASTER IDEALLY.
DOWN THERE SO PRETTY EXCITED
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO MAKE BALLOTS
THAT HAPPEN.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH I'D IN
THESE OTHER COMPANIES SO.
I'M.
I WILL. LEAVE IT AT THAT MAN
BRUCE FULL.
ALRIGHT IF ANY QUESTIONS AND BE
A WHAT WILL HOLD UP ON THE
QUESTIONS. AFTER MISTER WILLCOX
PRESENTATIONS OF. SADNESS
WILCOX'S THAT TIME IT.
AND I'M LIKE LIKE THIS PANEL UP
LET'S THAT SIR AND YEAH LET'S
GET SOME.
EXCITEMENT GOING ON HERE AID
BECAUSE I'VE GOT A LONG LIST OF
QUESTIONS AS WELL.
THAT THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE GET INTO I'M SURE SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
MIGHT HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AS
WELL I SHOULD MAKE THE TESTIMONY
AS LONG AS PASSED THE AYE.
WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
HAVE QUESTIONS AND GOING AWAY
ARM. I THINK TED PROVIDED A LOT
OF THE DETAIL I WAS YOU ARE THE.
LIGHT OF THE OVERVIEW THAT I WAS
GONNA PROVIDE.
BUT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF THINGS.
PARDON ME.
ANOTHER REMEMBER BACK WHEN WE
STARTED THIS.
ARE THE SONGS HE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO.
THERE WAS THIS GRAVE CONCERN
ABOUT THE NEED FOR.
SOME IMMEDIATE ACTION OF THE
SONGS. THERE WAS ALSO CONCERN
ABOUT A LONG RANGE PLAN FOR THE
SOLVENCY. THOSE TWO DON'T GO
TOGETHER VERY WELL IMMEDIATE
ACTION ON LONG RANGE PLAN.
SOLELY BIFURCATED THE PROCESS.
AND TO TO.
SEGMENTS ONE AS OF THE TEN YEAR
PLAN.
WHICH WAS APPROVED BY THE. WATER
POURED.
ALONG WITH A STIPULATED ORDER
AND THE OTHER IS A LONG RANGE
PLAN THAT WE ARE WORKING ON NOW.
AND WILL ENCOMPASS THE ENTIRE
CITY AND WILL LOOK AT.
ARE THINGS LIKE WATER IMPORT ON
NEXT WEEK.
WEEK AFTER NEXT.
A WERE HAD WE HAVE A PUBLIC
MEETING WITH THE. IMPERIAL
COUNTY ON THOSE.
WATER IMPORT PROJECTS.
AND THE GOAL OF THAT IS TRYING
TO DEFINE SOME THAT ARE. DIDN'T
MAKE THEM.
WITH FIT THE CRITERIA WE HAVE
FOR.
COST.
I IMPLEMENT HOW FAST WE CAN
IMPLEMENT THEM.
WHAT KIND OF ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTATION Y. NATICK SACHA?
SO THAT WILL START THE REVIEW
OF.
THE LONG RANGE PLAN THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THE LONG RANGE PLAN WILL BE
A WATER IMPORT PLAN. QUITE
FRANKLY. RIGHT NOW IT'S DESIGNED
AS A SMALLER BUT SUSTAINABLE
CITY PLAN. THAT HAS.
THE. ACCOUNTS FOR THE. EXPOS
PLAYA YOU SAW. TED TALK ABOUT
ALL OF THAT EXPOSED FLY AROUND
THE SOLVENCY.
NOW IT WILL BE BUILT SO THAT THE
LONG RANGE PLAN IF IT'S WATER
IMPORT. CAN STILL BE BUILT IN
OTHER WORDS WILL BUILD THE.
THE ARM.
THE BURNS HIGH ENOUGH THAT WE
CAN DO EITHER ONE.
THAT.
COSTS A LITTLE MORE QUITE
FRANKLY.
IT TAKES A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME
TO ENGINEER BUT IT GIVES US THE
FLEXIBILITY WE NEED LATER.
GIVEN THAT WE ARE.
WE HAVEN'T MADE A DECISION A
LONG RANGE PLAN TO THIS POINT.
.
ONE OF THE OTHER COMMENTS WAS
EARLIER WAS FEDERAL FUNDING.
AND WE HAVE A MINOR AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING.
WE HAVE AN AMMO YOU SIGNED WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
FOR.
MAY NOT HAVE MADE THE OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS FOR THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
THREE MILLION A YEAR PLUS OR
MINUS WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY MONEY
FROM THAT AGREEMENT CHAIR.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU KNOW.
EARLIER WAS ASKED WHAT COULD THE
STATE LEGISLATURE DO.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE STATE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT CONSIDER.
HIS LOOSENING THE RULES AND
PROPOSITION MONIES.
NOW THESE ARE OF THIS IS A WISH
LIST AND I DON'T KNOW HOW.
HOW OF WHETHER OR NOT?
THOSE SORT OF THINGS CAN BE
DONE.
BUT IF YOU REALLY IF YOU RELAX
THE RULES ON.
PROPOSITION MONEY YOU COULD
SPEND A LITTLE BIT MORE OF THAT
TIME.
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE WHICH
IS.
OF PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF SENSE
TO BUILD THIS.
PUT OUT A PRETTY ROBUST
OPERATION MAINTENANCE PROGRAM.
ARE I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
TOO ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF THE.
A GROUP THAT'S WORKING CANONISTS
UNFORTUNATELY.
HA SCAT IS LEAVING US.
AND LOTS WE GET THE LOCKS
CHANGED ON THE DOOR BEFORE HE
CAN TURN BEFORE IT GETS THERE.
BUT.
WE HAVE M. PROCESS.
TO IDENTIFY A NEW REPLACEMENT
SCAT HAS PROMISED TO HELP UNTIL
THAT REPLACEMENT COMES ON BOARD.
OH THERE WAS A LOT ACCOMPLISHED
AT THE DFW OFFICES.
IN THE LIKE THE TIME SCOUT WAS
THERE WE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS
AND HABITAT.
AND DONE PERMITTING AND OTHER
THINGS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN SO.
WE ARE UNKNOWN.
VERY GRATEFUL CATTLEYA FOR HIS
EFFORTS.
A TED IS IS BEEN WORKING ON THIS
PROJECT LONGER THAN I HAVE I
THINK.
A AND HAD HIS GROUP HAS PROVIDED
THAT SAME LEVEL OF SUPPORTER.
AND CONTINUES THROUGH PROVIDE
THAT SAME LEVEL OF SUPPORT. THEY
ARE ONE PERSON CHARTER. ALSO BUT
I THINK ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
FILLING THAT POSITION.
SO LET'S SAY WITHIN THREE TO SIX
MONTHS THOSE POSITIONS WILL
LOBBY FILLED.
I'M WILL HAVE A FULL CONTINGENCY
OF PEOPLE.
NOW AS WE GET.
AS WE START TO RAMP THIS UP.
THEY'RE PROBABLY THEY'RE NOT
PROBABLY THERE WILL BE MORE THAN
ONE PROJECT GOING AT THE SAME
TIME.
LEADER FROM A DESIGN
PERSPECTIVE.
OR A DESIGN AND BUILD
PERSPECTIVE OR BOTH.
AND WE PROBABLY WILL NEED MORE
PEOPLE.
AT THAT POINT IN TIME TO DEAL
WITH.
BUT OVER TED SHOULDER YOU CAN
SEE.
WHERE THE THE OVERALL STRUCTURE?
OF.
THE. DEPUTY EARLY.
AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR. ALONE
AND THE DIRECTOR ARE LISTED FOR
WATER RESOURCES.
AND THAT'S JUST NOT.
THAT'S JUST NOT A NAME UP THERE
CINDY IN PARTICULAR IS VERY
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS HELPING
US.
GET THROUGH SOME OF THE.
HICKS TODAY PICKUPS AND MANY.
PROCESS WOULD DEAL WE THERE'S
ALWAYS SOME ISSUES YOU GOT INTO.
SOLVE INTERNALLY.
I AM.
SAME WAY WITH JEANNIE CUDDLE IN
GENERAL THEY'VE BEEN VERY
HELPFUL ON THE DEVELOPMENT.
HA HA OF THE PLAN WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT SPLATTER WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO THEM FOR THAT TED FRINGS
GROUP.
ERIC COKE HAN HA.
HEART.
A NOT SO MUCH CHARGE BUT ERIC
HAS BEEN INVOLVED AND. AGAIN THE
IDEA OF HAVING HIGH LEVEL PEOPLE
IN THE ORGANIZATION HAVE
DEVELOPED.
TO HELP US MAKE DECISIONS AND TO
HELP US
HARM.
GET THROUGH HANA STICKING POINTS
OR.
OTHER POINTS IN THE PROCESS THAT
IT SIX MONTHS AGO WERE DEFEATING
US.
AND THERE ARE NO LONGER DOING
AND WE HAVE.
AND THEN EVEN FURTHER SAID TO
MOVE THAT ALONG.
AND IT'S NOT ON THIS ONE FED.
NARM WE HAVE A.
A COORDINATION PERSON THAT WORKS
BETWEEN DO WE.
ANDY W. ARE IN DFW. AND WOOD
WORKS THE SAME WAY WHETHER
CONSULTING TEAM.
TWO HA GET THROUGH THE DOE
REQUIREMENTS THE DELIVERY
REQUIREMENTS THERE. ARE BASED ON
PRETTY MUCH HARDSCAPE.
THIS IS NOT HARDSCAPE SO. ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
ADJUST. REQUIREMENTS SUCH THAT.
SUCH THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
THROUGH THE PROCESS FASTER DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF THE REVIEW
PROCESS.
THEN FINALLY.
WE HAVE HAD SOME ISSUES WITH
EASEMENTS.
I AM HAPPY TO SAY THAT WE HAVE.
I THINK.
I DON'T THINK I KNOW. WE'VE MADE
A LOT OF PROGRESS IN THAT. AND
THERE IS A HALF A DOZEN.
MEETINGS SCHEDULED OVER THE NEXT
COURSE OF THE NEXT MONTH OR SO.
TO FINISH THE EASEMENT ISSUE.
ONCE WE FINISH THESE MINUTES TO
ON THE.
SPECIES CONSERVATION HEALTHCARE
PROJECT WILL USE THAT AS A.
EXAMPLE FOR THE OTHER. HE IS A
MUSLIM THE OTHER IS NOW THE LAW
DIFFER SLIGHTLY.
BUT THEY'LL THEY'LL BE A.
PROCESS FOR DEVELOPING OZZY'S
AND.
AND PARTICULARLY WITH DESIGN
BILL. THAT PROCESS WILL INCLUDE
SOME KIND OF.
PHASED APPROACH TO E. IS
IMMENSE.
THERE WHERE.
.
WE LOOK AT AT A YOUNG DESIGNED
BILL ALLOWS YOU TO GET STARTED
EARLIER BUT IT DOES LOOK. IT
DOES REQUIRE ENGINEERING TO DO
THAT.
SO WE'LL LOOK AT HOW BEST.
WE. INTEGRATE THAT INTO THE
SYSTEM.
HOW BEST WE CAN INTEGRATE A
PAUSE IN THE SYSTEM AND A COUPLE
OF POINTS I HAD A COUPLE OF
POINTS?
TO ALLOW PUBLIC INPUT PUBLIC.
OUTREACH.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF SOME
REVIEW TIME BUT I AYE ID. ID'S
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED BECAUSE
THIS IS. PART OF THEIR DRAINAGE
SYSTEM OF.
I CONCERN VERY VALID KNOW THEY
NEED KEYPAD DRAINAGE SYSTEM
OPERATED.
I THINK.
THAT'S ABOUT ALL ON. THE.
POINTS ARE MAKE AND I'M.
AGAIN I'M JUST VERY PLEASED TO
THE AMOUNT OF PROGRESS THESE
GENTLEMEN HAVE MADE OVER THE.
LAST FEW MONTHS. THANK YOU
BRUCE.
AND THANK YU TO TO PALACE I
KNOW YOU ARE AWARE THAT THE.
HEARING IS BEING TELEVISED OUT
FOR STREAMLINED AND THAT WE HAVE
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
LOCALLY.
THAT ARE WATCHING THIS HEARING.
AND AS MUCH AS THEY WOULD LIKE
ME TO.
LIGHT UP YOU KNOW THE PRESENTERS
HERE.
THAT ARE HERE TODAY AND
ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT MY STYLE I
THINK I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I
EXPRESSED YOU. ATHEISTS HIGH
LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION.
THAT IS BEING CONVEYED TO ME AS
A PEOPLE OR CHIMING IN ON THE.
FACEBOOK Y. DEAL THEN THE TEXT
MESSAGING.
AS IT RELATES TO JUST THE ARM
CHALLENGE IN UNDERSTANDING YOU
KNOW OF THE PROCESS THAT YOU
WHILE JUST.
EXPLAINED
AND BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY I THINK WHAT PEOPLE ARMED
THERE WATCHING AND PERHAPS EVEN
THOSE THAT ARE HERE. UP
THEY WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
THEM THE ACTION STEPS AS IT
RELATES TO WHEN WE START SEEING
SOME CONSTRUCTION.
OUT THERE AND I KNOW YOU YOU'VE
GIVEN THIS OF A VAGUE OVERVIEW
OF WHERE WE'RE AT VAGUE MEANING
IN THE SENSE THAT WHEN DO WE GET
TO THE BEGINNING OF REACHING THE
FIRST CALL WHICH IS FIVE
HUNDRED.
PIRATE ACRES OF PROJECTS UNDER
CONSTRUCTION BY DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ACCORDING TO
THE ALLEY OFFICE. WORK WORK WORK
BEHIND ALREADY ON THAT
PARTICULAR PORTION THE FACT THAT
WE'RE HEARING THAT THERE ARE
POSITIONS THAT ARE GOING TO NO
LONGER BE FILLED AND IT'LL BE A
FEW MONTHS BEFORE WE ACTUALLY
FILL THOSE. ROLES THAT IN ITSELF
CREATES A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
CONCERN AS IT RELATES TO THE
TIMELINE THAT WE HAVE. MOVING
FORWARD AND SO AS MUCH AS THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SEE YOU KNOW WHAT WE GET TO
SEE ON. C-SPAN AND OTHER PLACES
WHERE WE HAD THE DIRECTORS OF
AGENCIES JUST GETTING LIT UP FOR
NOT ANSWERING QUESTIONS OR WHAT
NOT I'M NOT GONNA DO THAT. BUT
I'M CERTAINLY GOING TO ASK THAT
WE REALLY GIVE US SOME REALLY
POINTED ANSWERS
TO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
BY GOTTEN HERE BEFORE. OF MYSELF
AND I'M SURE SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AS WELL. SO I GUESS
THE FIRST THING IS HOW ARE WE
GOING TO TRY TO MAKE UP FOR THEM
A. TIMEFRAME THAT'S BEEN SET UP
AND THAT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD HAS SAID
SOME SOME BENCHMARKS FOR US TO
MEET. GIVEN THAT WE YOU HAVE
SOME TOOLS THAT DESIGN BUILD
COMPONENT TO BE ABLE TO CATCH
UP.
A AND WHEN WILL WE SEE THE FIRST
A CONSTRUCTION I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THE MAYBE AT THE END
OF THE YEAR BUT IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO. TO
EXPEDITE SOME OF THAT PROCESS IN
THE AISLE THAT ANYONE WHO WANTS
TO TAKE A STAB AT THAT QUESTION.
A JUMP RIGHT IN A PICK THE
FIRST.
THINK.
WE WILL START CONCERT
BY.
HIS BIGGEST TO THE MICROPHONE
FIRST PLAY WILL ALSO WON'T WE
WILL START CONSTRUCTION BY
DECEMBER.
WHO THE WATER ORDER DOES GIVE
US A SECOND YEAR? TO HIT CAUGHT
UP INTO SUPERIOR THE FIRST YEAR
SO. WOULD BE HARD TO KEEP UP
BECAUSE.
OF THE SIZE OF THE PROJECT TO
TAKE SEVERAL YEARS TO BUILD THE
PROJECT. ONCE YOU'VE GOT A BILL
THAT THEATER NINE HUNDRED ACRES.
BUT UNTIL YOU GET A BILL THAT
DOESN'T COUNT TOWARDS THE.
A TOTAL SO WE HAVE TWO YEARS.
ARE WE ARE IN THE PROCESS RIGHT
NOW OF DEVELOPING. WERE REQUIRED
TO DEVELOP.
A PLAN FOR TO GET CAUGHT UP.
YOU SAW OF THE WHAT.
TED CALLED THE ALCOTT ROAD
PROJECT THAT'S ONE OF THE
ANSWERS TO.
HOW DO WE SPEED UP AND HOW DO WE
MOVE THIS FORWARD?
ARM.
THE.
I THINK THEY'RE FROM FROM THE
POINT OF VIEW OF.
OF THE LEGISLATURE YOU FOLKS
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE.
AND PROVIDING.
FUNDING AND HABITAT.
CAN I DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC.
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LEGISLATURE
THERE ARE SUGGESTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AT THIS POINT.
.
I THINK HEARINGS LIKE THIS HELP
BECAUSE THEY DO PUT US ON.
NOTICE THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD.
I THINK INVOLVING OUR PARTNERS
IN THE HEARING IS IS ALSO A
GREAT IDEA.
MOVING FORWARD.
<c.red> SHOULD HAVE SAID THIS
EARLIER</c>
I IDEA IN THE LAST MONTH OR SO.
TWO LINES HAS BEEN VERY VERY
HELPFUL.
YEAH AND MOVING.
OF AN S. C. H. NSCA JUST SORT OF
THE CORNERSTONE. OF THE PROJECTS
MOVING FORWARD SO. THAT'S THE
PROJECT TO GET STARTED IN
DECEMBER.
THAT'S OUR FIRST PROJECT.
AND THEN WE MOVED TO THE OTHER
SIDE OF THEM SLIMMY ASK A
QUESTION BECAUSE WE ARE AB.
DELAYED ALREADY WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PROJECT OR
THAT PROJECT.
DOES THAT AUTOMATICALLY DELAY US
FROM MOVING FORWARD WITH OTHER
PROJECTS THAT ARE WITHIN THE.
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
IT DOESN'T AND WE HAVE THE NORTH
LAKE THAT WE IS A RELATIVELY NEW
PROJECTS.
PROMOTED BY RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND TO SOME EXTENT BY THE. SOUND
SEE AT THE ORGAN.
AND WERE WORKING ON THE DESIGN
OF THAT AS WE SPEAK.
.
HABITAT OF THE WEST OF THE
RIVER.
WILL BE DESIGNED AND WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT AS WE SPEAK.
AS I MENTIONED THE ALCOTT
WETLAND.
IS BEING DEVELOPED. RIGHT NOW
WHILE WE'RE STILL WORKING
THROUGH THESE MENDACIOUS NOW ALL
OF THOSE HAVE THESE MONEY
ISSUES.
BUT ONCE WE GET ONE WORKED OUT I
THINK WE CAN.
WORKOUT THE OTHERS FASTER
THERE'S ALSO A.
NORTH IN PROJECT WITH TORRES
MARTINEZ.
THAT HANNAH HAD ACTUALLY HAS THE
BENEFIT OF NOT HAVING QUITE AS
MANY.
REGULATIONS ATTACHED TO IT.
AND WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH.
I GETTING HOME PAYS RENTS FOR
THAT SO THAT WE CAN.
SO WE CAN EXTEND TENURE TO BUILD
HARD TO BUILD THINGS WHILE WE'RE
WAITING TO FINIAL FINALIZE.
SOME OF THE ISSUES ON THE LARGER
SCALE PROJECTS.
OKAY I WANTED TO. ASK THE
QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO THE
EASEMENTS BECAUSE YOU'VE
MENTIONED THAT A COUPLE TIMES
AND I THINK ON THE GROUND. IT'S
BEEN.
SAID THAT THERE'S IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT.
TO COME TO AN UNDERSTANDING WITH
THE OTHER PARTNERS ARE AGENCIES
INVOLVED IN THIS CAN YOU TELL US
WHAT HAS BEEN THE CHALLENGE. AND
WHAT IT IS THAT.
WEEKEND SET UP IN PLACE TO TRY
TO AVOID OR ELIMINATE THESE
TYPES OF.
LONG LASTING NO NEGOTIATIONS ARE
DELAYING.
REALLY THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
PROJECT.
THE BIGGEST DELAY HAS BEEN A
ESTABLISHING LIABILITY.
FOR THE EXISTING PLY AND NOT THE
PROJECTS.
AND OBVIOUSLY IDEA WOULD LIKE.
THAT LIABILITY COVERAGE AN
OBVIOUSLY. WERE NOT TOO
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT GIVING WE
DON'T MIND. GIVING IT ON THE
PROJECTS THAT'S A LITTLE BIT.
TOUGHER FOR US TO GIVE US.
I ABILITY UNDER EXISTING.
CLAIMS OUT THERE ARE EXISTING
PROBLEMS OUT THERE. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
DO.
HERE'S PASSED SOME KIND OF
LIMITATION.
OUR TIME.
APPLY A PROJECTS INSOLVENCY
PROJECTS.
THE TAKE TOOK THAT LIABILITY
ISSUE AWAY.
DOES THE LIABILITY THAT THE
STATE HAS BY THE SIGN NEAR THE
CUBA SAY NOT.
CLEARLY MAKE IT THAT STATE
LIABILITY ISSUE THEREFORE THIS
BACK AND FORTH WITH AYE ID WOULD
BE REALLY.
NOT AVOID IT IT RELATED TO THE
PROJECT THAT DOES.
RELATED TO EXISTING CONDITIONS
THAT THE SOUND CITY.
OUR ATTORNEYS BELIEVE IT DOES
NOT.
AND THAT'S THE CERCLA CONCERNS.
ON APPLY OF PREVIOUS.
TOM.
CONTAMINATION WITH PESTICIDES
HERBICIDES OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
I MEAN IT MAYBE I MAYBE BECAUSE
I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY I AM I
MISSING THE THE.
POINT THERE. BUT THE END IN THE
BIG PICTURE I MEAN WE HAVE A
HUGE LIABILITY OUT THERE. THAT
ULTIMATELY FALLS ON THE SIDE OF
THE STATE AND IF WERE GOING BACK
AND FORTH ON THIS TYPE OF UP.
DETAILED MAY BE OF SIGNIFICANCE.
I MAYBE IT'S NOT REGISTERING
WITH ME I THINK WE'RE PUTTING.
AT RISK A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
LIABILITY THAT WE HAVE OUT
THERE.
BY THE SIMPLE FACT OF HAVING IT
NEGOTIATED A NEEDS MET RIGHT
AWAY AND. MAYBE I'M MISSING
SOMETHING HERE BECAUSE I THINK
WELL I I DON'T I THINK I DID A
BAD JOB OF EXPLAINING.
.
THERE ARE SOME STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR OF THE STATE.
WHEN IT COMES THE LIABILITY.
AND THOSE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
ARE WAS GETTING IN THE WAY.
SO IS THAT AN AREA THAT WE.
COULD TAKE A LOOK AT IT BECAUSE
AS YOU JUST MENTIONED ONCE WE
GET THIS ONE EASEMENT ISSUE.
IN PLACE.
THAT WILL SEPARATE STUDENT
MOVING FORWARD ARE WE GONNA HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THIS PROJECT BY
PROJECT.
AS WE GO THROUGH THE MANAGEMENT
PLAN.
THAT'LL SET PRECEDENT MOVING
FORWARD NOW HAVING SAID THAT.
EACH PROJECT WILL HAVE A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT NEW I'M
STILL.
BUT THE ISSUE OF LIABILITY.
WELL HAVE BEEN DEALT.
WHAT'S THE INTERNAL STRUCTURE OF
KIND OF DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE
LIKE WHO WHO GETS TO MOVE ON TO
TAKE THE LEAD ON THIS AND HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY. SET SOME BENCHMARKS
TO BE ABLE TO MEET SOME OF THESE
CALLS AND SAY WE'VE GOT TWENTY
FIVE DAYS THIRTY DAYS TO FIGURE
THIS OUT BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT.
CHALLENGE BEFORE IS WHAT WHAT IS
THAT SYSTEM LOOK LIKE.
THE DWI ATTORNEY.
AND MYSELF AND ITS DELIBERATELY
LIMITED TO A COUPLE PEOPLE.
I HAD AYE ID'S REQUEST AND AND I
REQUEST MAKES MORE SENSE TO
HAVE.
ONE OR TWO PEOPLE NEGOTIATING
SOMETHING LIKE THIS NINE FIVE OR
SIX.
ARE FROM MARS.
SCHEDULE POINT OF VIEW.
I THINK WE BOTH BOTH AGENCIES
ARE. PLANNING TO HAVE THIS DONE
BY THE END OF MAY.
WE HAVE PROBABLY FLOOR.
MAYBE FOR A I THINK FOR MEETINGS
BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF MAY.
ALL DAY MEETINGS.
TO RESOLVE THIS I JUST WENT
THROUGH.
ONE OF THOSE ALL DAY MEETINGS HE
OTHER DAY. I HAVE A NEW
APPRECIATION FOR ATTORNEYS AND
THEIR PATIENTS.
AND. THEN HOW MUCH THEY MAKE.
WELL BECAUSE THAT'S I MEAN WE WE
WE WE WE'RE GONNA SPEND LOT OF
MONEY ON. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
EVEN RIGHT AWAY I MEAN WE.
PART OF THE ALLEY O. REPORT SAYS
WE WE STILL HAVE SOME WAYS TO GO
TO. BE ABLE TO MEET THE OVERALL.
FUNDING OBLIGATIONS WERE WHERE
WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE THAT YOU
KNOW PROP SIXTY EIGHT IS IN GOOD
POSITION TO POSSIBLY BASS.
THE BUT.
BALLOT THAT IN NOVEMBER WILL SET
US UP BUT THAT'S.
MAYBE
WELL LOT OF MAYBE MONEY ON THE
TABLE FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PLAN AND THAT'S THAT DOESN'T
GIVE ME A LOT OF. CONFIDENCE IN
SO I AM YOU KNOW I'M I'M BEING
FACETIOUS ABOUT THAT CHINESE
BUT.
THE FACT IS THAT YOU KNOW IT IS
COSTING US MONEY AND TIME TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PLAN AND I
AM IS OF A BIG CONCERT LOTS OF
MONEY.
THAT. WE SET ASIDE TWENTY ANY
OTHER CHALLENGES THAT WE
NEED TO.
BE TAKING A LOOK AT BEFORE
DECEMBER CONSTRUCTION BEGINS AND
WE RUN INTO A SITUATION WHERE
IT'S LIKE WE DIDN'T ANTICIPATE
THAT MULTIMILLION HE. OUT WE
WON'T START CONSTRUCTION UNTIL
TWO DOZEN NINETEEN I MEAN JANIE
THING THAT WE NEED TO BE PAYING
CLOSE ATTENTION TO. OUT RIGHT
NOW.
NOT THAT I'M.
COMING TO MIND RIGHT NOW THAT
THE DESIGN BUILD PROCESS
AUTHORITY THAT WE HAVE IS IS I
THINK OUR BASS.
BATS FOR MOVING THINGS FORWARD
AND HAS. JUST TO POINT OUT I
MEAN YOU GUYS HAVE THE REFERENCE
LOVE OF THE LAND HOLDINGS IN
AUTHORITIES THERE. AND IT. THE
STATE DOESN'T HAVE AUTHORITY
OVER MUCH IF ANY OF THESE LAND
YEAH IT'S ALL GONNA REQUIRED
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS.
AND CERTAINLY IN THE SOUTH AND
THE NORTH AND SEE ITS I ID AT W.
TRIBAL ENGAGEMENT.
.
THOSE PROCESSES ARE JUST GONNA
BE WHAT WE HAVE TO WORK THROUGH
I THINK ALBUM.
THE.
THE MAKING PROGRESS IN GETTING
THAT COMFORT BELT THAT A BETWEEN
PARTNERSHIPS I THINK IS GONNA GO
ON WAYS.
WE MIGHT LOOK AT.
WAYS THAT WE CAN SHORTEN OUR
STREAMLINE.
THE BIDDING PROCESS WE DO HAVE
SOME GETTING.
INVOLVED IN THIS AND WE DON'T
WANT TO GIVE UP THE. OPTION FOR
BED OVER DESIGN.
BILL WHAT'S PREVENTING US FROM
DOING THAT.
NOTHING.
WE JUST THINK THAT DESIGN BUILD
THIS FASTER.
BUT LET'S SAY SOMETHING.
THAT.
CAUSES.
HOUSE TO.
CAUSES US TO HAVE A DELAY IN THE
DESIGN BUILD PROCESS.
HOW WE COULD FALL BACK AND THE
DESIGN SAID FILLED PROCESS?
AND IF WE HAD SOME TIME.
SOME ABILITY TO SHORTEN THE
TIME.
HOW THE ADVERTISEMENT IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL?
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT DOING NOW HOURS AT UP
TO WERE WAITING I THINK WE
SHOULD.
DO YOU NEED DIRECTION FROM.
SOMEONE ELSE DO YOU NEED DAHLE
OUR INSISTENCE AND PUSHING THAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT WOULD IT REQUIRED
TO MOVE.
IN THAT DIRECTION IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE KNOW THAT THAT WILL HELP US.
SHORTEN THE TIMEFRAME.
WILL LOOK TO SEE IF IT
MYERS WELL.
USE IT TAKE QUESTIONS COLLEAGUE.
AND I APOLOGIZE I JUST WALKED IN
BUT IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM LIKE.
I JUST IN THE BRIEF TIME THAT
ARE HERE THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING ANY ANSWERS.
THE CHAIRS ASKING YOU INSTEAD
OF YOU DIRECTLY THEY WHAT CAN WE
DO AND YOU'RE NOT GIVING US A
DIRECT ANSWERS TO WHAT WE CAN DO
TO MOVE THIS ALONG. IT QUITE
FRANKLY I'M GETTING FRUSTRATED
JUST.
KIND OF WEIRD SITTING URGES.
HAVING CONVERSATION INSTEAD OF
ACTUALLY ANY KIND OF RESULTS I
KNOW IT'S AN OVERSIGHT HEARING
BY.
I'VE GOTTEN FROM THE FEW
MINUTES I'VE BEEN HERE DOT WERE
BEHIND IN THE PROJECT THERE IS
NO CLEAR ANSWER AS TO WHAT'S
GOING TO GET US BACK ON TRACK.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE.
ARE THE REASON FOR THE DIE
HEARING IS BECAUSE THEY ARE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S THERE'S A
PROBLEMS AND WE'RE NOT HEARING
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP THIS
PROCESS ALONG.
A.
SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID THERE'S NO
CLEAR PROCESS TO GET SPECIAL.
THERE IS A CLEAR PROCESS TO GET
US BACK ON TRACK.
WELL REQUIRED BY THE STIPULATED
WATER OR.
TO PUT TOGETHER A PLAN TO GET US
BACK ON TRACK.
AND THAT WOULD SPECIFICALLY
OUTLINED PROJECTS.
FROM A SPECIFIC POINT OF VIEW.
WE'LL HAVE CONSTRUCTION STARTED.
AND SPECIES CONSERVATION HABITAT
BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
THAT SAID DESIGN BID BUILD
PROJECT.
IT TAKES A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME.
TO POUND THE DESIGN STUFF.
BUT IT TAKES A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME TO COMPLETE THESE BONDS.
AND THEN TAKE IT OUT FOR. GET
CONTRACTS OR.
THE PROJECT AND THE EAST SIDE OF
THE RIVER.
OUR THERE'S A PACKET THERE
SHOULD BE A HAND ON HER PACKET.
WITH THE SCHEDULE.
AND THOSE THEIR NEXT AND WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD.
A LOT ALONG WITH.
THE SPECIES CONSERVATION AREAS.
AREAS TO THE NORTH WHICH WE JUST
STARTED WORKING ON.
WITH THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN
PROBABLY A MONTH AGO.
WILL BE DESIGNED OVER THE NEXT
THREE MONTHS.
AND.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO WE HAVE TO
FINALIZE SOME HYDROLOGY.
WITH THEN WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
SCHEDULE A TIME FRAME ON THOSE.
NOTED THAT PROJECT JUST CAME UP.
SO WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN TOO FAR
ALONG AND THAT BUT THAT'S THE
NEXT. THAT'S THE NEXT PRIORITY.
I I DID OUTLINE A FEW THINGS
THAT THE. LEGISLATURE CAN DO
QUITE FRANKLY.
A LOT OF WHAT THE.
HOW WERE THE DELAYS ARE I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT'S OF?
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THESE ARE THE
LASER.
BECAUSE BY REVIEW PERIODS OR.
.
SOME KIND OF.
OF NEGOTIATION OF WHO WOULD I
CAME TO THE.
LEGISLATURE SIX MONTHS AGO WITH
THE.
CONTAMINATION ISSUE WE MIGHT BE
FURTHER ALONG WE DIDN'T THAT WAS
MY HAIR. WE SHOULD.
ARM BUT I DON'T I DON'T THINK.
BEYOND WHAT I LISTENED ALREADY
THERE'S A SPLIT THERE'S A
SPECIFIC THINGS THAT YOU CAN DO.
CERTAIN BUT MY CONCERN IS.
AGAIN JUST IN THOUGH IN THAT
CONVERSATION EARLIER YOU STATED
THAT.
THOUGH THAT THIS IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US HAVE THESE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS SO WE CAN BACK GET BACK
ON TRACK THAT'S WHAT THREW ME
OFF OF THE CONVERSATION IS. YEAH
WELL SO WHAT I'M HEARING IS IF
WE DON'T HAVE THE OVERSIGHT OP
MEETINGS THAT WE WOULDN'T BE ON
TRACK AND THAT'S WHAT MY CONCERN
IS.
USE THAT YOU SAID ABOUT TWO OR
THREE TIMES AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE THESE
HEARINGS. AND SO THAT'S
CONCERNING TO ME BECAUSE I IT
BASICALLY MEANS TO ME THAT IF WE
DON'T KEEP YOU ABA KEEP BRINGING
YOU BACK THAT THAT THIS IS NOT.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT GOING TO OUR
CONTINUE THE PROJECT AND THAT'S
WHAT TO ME OFF.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU IS THAT IF
WE DON'T KEEP HAVING THESE
HEARINGS WERE NOT GONNA BE ON
TRACK WHILE I'M EXPECTING BAD.
WEATHER WE HAVE THE HEARINGS ARE
NOT THAT WE SHOULD BE ON TRACK
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF
THE THE PROJECT ITSELF.
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
WHEN I UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY AND
AND.
MY FRUSTRATION LEVEL IS AS HIGH
AS YOURS QUITE FRANKLY.
IT HAS TAKEN OZONE AQUARIA LONG
TIME TO GET HERE. THE REFERENCE
TO THE MEETINGS OR I THINK IT
HELPS US.
.
FROM THE POINT OF VIEW OF TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
WE CAN'T REACH OUT TO EVERYONE.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER WAY WE CAN
REACH OUT TO PEOPLE AND INFORM
THEM WHAT'S GOING ON. LOOK AT
WHAT BUT WHY CAN'T WE REACH OUT
TO EVERYONE.
WELL WE DON'T HAVE THE. TIME OR
THE RESOURCES TO REACH OUT TO
EVERYONE SO IF YOU CATCH.
SOME PEOPLE.
I AM PUBLIC OUTREACH MEETINGS.
AND YOU CATCH SOME PEOPLE AND
SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND YOU CATCH SOME PEOPLE HERE
AS JUST ANOTHER METHOD OF
COMMUNICATION.
I THINK THAT THAT LEADS TO A A
GOOD POINT AND A GOOD QUESTION
IN TERMS OF THE APPROPRIATE THAT
LEVEL OF STAFFING THAT THAT
PERHAPS IS AVAILABLE.
TO YOU BRUCE AND THAT TO THE
REST OF THE TEAM. I'M.
YOU MAY NOT SAY THIS BUT I THINK
THE PERHAPS.
TAKE AWAY HERE IS THAT YOU MAY
NOT HAVE. THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF
PEOPLE.
TO DO THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE YEAR WHICH IS PART OF.
WHAT'S DELAYED AT THIS
CONVERSATION WHICH HAS ALSO LED
TO A CONVERSATION. OF SETTING UP
A STRUCTURE WHETHER BE A FORMAL
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OR AND. A
TASK FORCE THAT GOING TO HELP
STREAMLINE SOME OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND MAKE SURE THAT
IF IT'S.
OUT REACH STAFF THAT THAT NEEDS
TO BE PUT IN PLACE SO BE IT TO
IN ORDER TO GET THE MESSAGE OUT.
WE GOT BACK TO MY POINT THOUGH
IF THAT'S THAT IF THAT'S THE
REASON DIDN'T BUT THAT SHOULD BE
SAID INSTEAD OF APPLIED.
I'M A YOU KNOW IF WE CAN SAY I
DON'T HAVE PROPER STAFFING
INSTEAD OF GOING ABOUT YOU KNOW
SAYING YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
THE PROPER RESOURCES. INSTEAD OF
ASKING US FOR THOSE RESOURCES I
THINK THAT'S WHAT I'M EXPECTING
IS WHAT DO YOU NEED. AND AYE
WHEN I MADE THE GUY I ASKED
QUESTION YOU SAID WE DON'T HAVE
YOU KNOW THE PROPER OUTREACH
WELL THAT WASN'T INDICATED.
EARLIER IF YOU DON'T SAY IT THEN
I'M GONNA SOME THAT YOU DO.
AND SO THAT'S ITEM MY INTENT FOR
BEING HERE IS THAT I WOULD HEAR
WHAT WE CAN DO. AND AND MAYBE WE
CANNOT FIX SAID LEGISLATIVELY
BUT IF YOU NEED MORE STAFF AND
THAT'S SHOULD IT SHOULD OF BEEN
SAID.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET FROM HERE BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY LIKE I SAID I'M NOT
GIVING. YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST
HAVING A CONVERSATION INSTEAD OF
ADDED SOME KIND WHEN ACTION PLAN
OR SOME KIND OF AN* WE WE
CAN HELP YOU ALONG.
SO THEY'VE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FACE WANTING
YOUR MANAGEMENT PLAN BUT I WANT
TO SPEND SOME TIME ON SPEAKING
ABOUT THE PLAN. TO GET BACK ON
TRACK WITH THE PLAN. IN SO WHEN
CAN WE EXPECT. THAT TO BE
PRESENTED TO US ADAM. WHAT'S THE
TIMEFRAME ON THAT.
SO THEN THAT'S THAT THE PLAN O
GET BACK ON TRACK WITH THE PLAN.
WELL WE PLAN TO OUR.
WE'LL HAVE THAT BY THE END OF
JUNE OKAY.
OKAY SO SO WOULDN'T YOU KNOW
WE'LL BE GETTING BACK TOGETHER
PERHAPS AFTER JUNE BUT I THINK
IT'S THAT'S GOING TO BE.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE.
I'M HOPING THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THE VISION THAT I HAVE AND I
THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE IN THE.
SOLVENCY AREAS.
HAD THAT LIVE IN THAT AREA.
ARE ARE ENVISIONING THAT THE
STATE AT SOME POINT IF IN FACT
BY THE END OF THE YEAR. THERE'S
CLOSE TO FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS COMMITTED TO THIS FIRST
PHASE.
THAT DIE IN ESSENCE WOULD BE
FULLY FUNDED THAT THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY OF SEEN PROJECTS
UNDER CONSTRUCTION. IN THE NORTH
SOUTHEAST WEST OF THE CITY RIGHT
THAT THERE WILL BE MULTIPLE
PROJECTS BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE'RE SENDING A.
VERY POSITIVE OUTLOOK ON THAT
AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME OF. WERE
JUST NOT.
READY TO START ONE PROJECT AND
SO IT YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I WANTED HIM. IN SHARE WITH
YOU THAT UP PEOPLE.
ENVISIONED HAPPENING OUT THERE
AT SOME POINT WE HAVE A PLAN
WITH MONEY.
THAT THERE BE NO REASON WHY
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU'VE GOT THE
THE TOOLS AND THE SHY OF MAY BE
THE FULL RESOURCES TO DO THE
OUTREACH.
.
TO BE ABLE TO GET THESE PROJECTS
UNDER CONSTRUCTION
ABOVE.
WE NEED TO.
ANTICIPATE.
MORE THAN ONE KIND OF PROJECTS
UNDER CONSTRUCTION AT THE SAME
TIME.
THE NORTH IN PROJECT IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE LITTLE BE UNDER
CONSTRUCTION.
ANY OTHER SPECIES CONSERVATION
HABITAT. OR THE AREA TO THE
RIGHT WEST OF THE RIVER I DON'T
KNOW WHICH.
SPECIES CONSERVATION HAVE A CAT
HAS CONSTRUCTED FIRST IF WE GOT
THAT DONE READ MOVE TO THE WEST
OF THE RIVER. CITING REPRESSED
WE ANTICIPATE HAVING TO. MAYBE
THREE OF ITS CERTAINLY TWO
PROJECTS GOING ON AT THE SAME
TIME.
AND.
WHEN WE GET THERE OR AS WE GET
CLOSE TO THEIR ANOTHER PROJECT
MANAGER OR TO.
HOA OR ENGINEER WOULD BE
SOMETHING WE WOULD BE LOOKING
FOR THAT'S IN NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET.
YEAH BUT YOU'RE.
AUSTIN'S ARE PERTINENT AND RIGHT
ON POINT FOR THE DEPARTMENT WE
DO HAVE.
STAFFING ISSUES.
WE COULD USE ADDITIONAL STAFF
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY.
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT ACTIONS.
ALMOST SIMULTANEOUSLY TO MEET
AND GET BACK ON TRACK AS YOU'RE
POINTING OUT MAYBE I DIDN'T DO A
GOOD ENOUGH JOB OF CLARIFYING
THAT WE HAVE MULTIPLE PROJECTS
UNDER DESIGN RIGHT NOW AND. WE
EXPECT THEM TO BE THE NEXT STEPS
AND HOME AND IN CONSTRUCTION NOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE. GOING TO BE
SOME OFFSET IN TIME JUST BECAUSE
OF THE DESIGN PROCESS THAT GOES
ON AND THEN THE CONTRACTING
PROCESS THAT WILL GO ON BUT. WE
ARE ON TRACK IN THE.
HAND OUT. HERE BUT THE ONE THAT
SHOWED A LITTLE MORE DETAIL IN
THE RIVER WEST AREA.
THE DESIGN BUILD PROCESS WILL
LET US MOVE TO THE WEST OF NEW
RIVER AND.
ACTUALLY GET A PROJECT
IMPLEMENTED.
AS QUICKLY AS ANYTHING ONCE WE
GET THE EASEMENT.
AGREEMENT SETTLED.
VAN THE. ALCOTT ROAD PROJECT IS
THE OTHER PROJECT THAT WILL GET
US TOWARDS AT LEAST THAT FIVE
HUNDRED ACRES AND SO BETWEEN
THOSE TWO.
NEW RIVER WEST AND THE ALCOTT
PROJECT. WE WILL BE. ON TRACK
WITH THOSE PROJECTS TO START
MEETING THOSE STIPULATED ORDER.
ACREAGES BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK AND I AM BECAUSE OF THOSE
ANNUAL TARGETS IT STACKS UP VERY
FAST ON THE DEPARTMENT. HOA THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS DOESN'T GO
BACK QUICKLY TO GET SOMETHING
DESIGNED AND OUT THE CONTRACT ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS. IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE HAVE THAT QUESTION
HERE FROM WHAT I JUST HEARD.
THAT I CAN APPRECIATE THAT YOU
SAY THAT TO OTHERS LOT OF WORK
BUT THEN WE KNOW THIS IN THE
BEGINNING.
WELL THE STIPULATED ORDER WAS A
NEW THING THAT WAS.
MAY KNOW THAT THE OF THE
PLANNING PROCESS WE UNDERSTAND
FROM A DEPARTMENT.
BOB PERSPECTIVE OF.
USUALLY IT TAKES YOU KNOW A YEAR
MAYBE UP TO TWO YEARS TO DO
DESIGN. AND THEN YOU GIVE
YOURSELF
SOMEWHERE OUT NINE TO TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD TO GET TO A
CONTRACT AND THEN YOU WORK
THROUGH THE CONSTRUCTION OF. A
TWO OF THREE A FIVE YEAR DEPEND
UPON THIS SUNDAY ON SCIENCE THE
PROJECT LET ME ADD OTHER
HOUSEHOLDER THAT OUR. PETS THE
REASON FOR THE DESIGN BILL.
WE CAN GET THAT UNDER CONTRACT.
MUCH FASTER.
AND WE CAN ACTUALLY BE
CONSTRUCTING.
PART OF THE PROJECT OUR
DESIGNING THE OTHER PART OF THE
PROJECT.
SAU WAS THE IDEA BEHIND A SIGN
DON'T.
TRY TO SPEED THAT PROCESS UP.
BECAUSE THERE'S AN EXAMPLE I
THINK.
OF A PROCESS THAT IS.
BEEN COMPRESSED AS MUCH AS WE
CAN COMPRESS IT IT JUST TAKES
THAT LONG TO GET THROUGH THAT
PROCESS.
WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WAYS.
THE WAY MY COMPRESSORS AND MATT
HAS BEEN ON BOARD FOR WHAT THREE
WEEKS OR SO.
HARD TO COORDINATE THAT AND SEE
IF THERE ARE WAYS TO COMPRESS IT
EVEN FURTHER.
BUT AFTER THAT AFTER A CERTAIN
POINT.
THERE JUST ISN'T ANY MORE SWEET
ZERO I MEAN YOU CAN'T.
YOU CAN COMPRESS THAT BEYOND YOU
HAVE TO HAVE CERTAIN.
HAVE TO HAVE CERTAIN HARM.
TIME FRAMES FOR THE.
FOR THEY ADVERTISEMENT AND
THINGS LIKE THAT ASSISTING
AND THAT'S JUST A GIVEN CONCERT
CHARDON MATT GOOD HARTMAN OF OUR
WATER RESOURCES AND WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF THE HEARINGS AS
RELATES TO THE OROVILLE. DAM
PROJECT.
AND CLEARLY AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT FOR
CALIFORNIA IT'S WATER RELIANCE.
AND SUPPLY YOU KNOW FOR THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM.
AND WE'VE UP REACTED.
IN A VERY EXPEDITIOUS AND
IN A RESPONSIVE MANNER TO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUEAYE I'M
WONDERING. HOW DO WE COMPARE AS
IT RELATES TO THE LEVEL OF?
TIME ENERGY AND RESOURCES I
WHEN WE TALKING ABOUT CAPACITY
WHETHER BE OUT REACH.
STAFF OR FOR THAT MATTER BEING
ABLE TO MOVE THE DESIGN BUILD
PROCESS.
ACCORDING TO THE SCHEDULES WHAT
WHERE WHERE DO WE WHERE DO WE
FALL WITHIN YOU KNOW THE CONTEXT
OF THE.
NOT SO MUCH RANKING THE LEVEL OF
IMPORTANCE BECAUSE I WOULD SAY
THAT THEY'RE BOTH EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BUT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THE PRESSURES HERE A
BIT DIFFERENT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PUBLIC CAL ECOSYSTEM
DILAPIDATION. ARE GOING ON WE
HAVE A PLAN WE'VE GOT SOME MONEY
WHAT WHERE DO WE WHERE WE SEE
OURSELVES IN COMPARISON TO. HOW
WE'RE RESPONDING TO OUR THE
CRISIS IN THE SALTON SEA VERSES
THE OROVILLE DAM ARE STARTING
TED ME HAVE SOME COMMENTS ON
WERE ABILITY WAS INVOLVED IN OUR
EMAIL?
I THINK WE ARE SLOWER THAN
OROVILLE.
AND WE COULD LOOK AT WHY WE
COULD LOOK AT. THAT TO SEE IF
THERE WAS.
AND EMERGENCY DECLARED OR WHAT
PROCESS WAS USED.
AT OROVILLE THAT COULD SPEED
THINGS UP BECAUSE CERTAINLY.
THAT WAS AN EXPEDITED SCHEDULE.
SO WE WILL LOOK INTO THAT.
IT IS THERE IS THERE.
AN EMERGENCY THAT NEEDS TO BE
DECLARED.
AS RELEASES ON BECAUSE I THINK
I MEAN LOCALLY WE I THINK
LOCALLY WE'VE DECLARED IT AS. A
A STATE OF EMERGENCY IS STATE OF
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT.
OF ECONOMIC THREAT OUGHT TO THE
REGION I MEAN IS THERE A
SOMETHING OF THAT SORT OF ACTION
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE AS A
LEGISLATURE OR IS THAT SIMPLY.
UPON THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO
MAKE THAT CALL I DON'T KNOW
WHOLE RESEARCH AND FIND OUT.
I THINK THE GOVERNOR HAS TO MAKE
THE CALL.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR WE CAN MAKE THE CALL
BUT IF YOU'RE SAYING THAT THAT'S
WHAT'S REQUIRED THEN ASK US TO
ASK THE GOVERNOR TO MAKE THAT
CALL OWNERS WE CAN.
I MEAN THAT IT WHAT I'M HEARING
IS IF THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES THEN
I THINK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AND I WE
ARE WILLING TO.
ASKED THE GOVERNOR TO DO THAT
BUT THAT'S THE POINT THAT'S I'M
GOING BACK TO WHAT I SAID
ORIGINALLY IF YOU DON'T TELL US
WHAT WE CAN DO THAT WE CAN
EXPEDITE ANYTHING IF IF THAT'S
WHAT THE REQUIRED MEANT AS. WELL
AS THE GOVERNOR I I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S A REQUIREMENT WE'RE
GONNA LOOK INTO IT COULD IT
COULD HELP SO WE'LL LOOK INTO IT
AND SAY.
THANK YOU I GOT TO ONE QUESTION
ONE FINAL QUESTION WE HAVE
ANOTHER PANEL AWAITING. YOU KNOW
THE WATER POUR REQUIRES ANYA
REPORTING UNDER THE PHASE
WANTING YOUR PLAN.
DO MULTIPLE DEPARTMENT PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE WATER BOARD
TO THE REPORT TO YOU.
I THIS REPORTING CHO NOT POINTS
ON C. PROJECTS THAT ARE NOT IN
THE TEN YEAR PLAN OTHER WORDS
WHAT. ARE WE KIND OF TRYING TO
KEEP EACH OTHER AND. ARE ALL OF
US.
TO THE SCHEDULE AND ACCOUNTABLE
TO.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE?
HARLAN.
WE WERE IRATE TO REPORT NATURAL
RESOURCES RIGHTS REPORT.
.
US ARUM.
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND DWI WILL
PROVIDE US INFORMATION.
I AS MY TIME MAY OTHERS US FISH
WILDLIFE ANOTHER IS THE IDEA IS
TO TRY TO GIVE A PICTURE.
SNAPSHOT PICTURE WHERE WERE
ADDED CONSULTANCY.
SO ANY OF THOSE AGENCIES ARE
OTHERS OF.
REGIONAL BOARD. COULD WEIGH EN.
HARM.
SECOND HALF YEAR QUESTION LAWS
SO I MEAN THERE'S THERE ARE
PROJECTS THAT ARE NOT IN THE
PLAN.
AND HOW ARE WE.
KEEPING TABS OF THOSE PROJECTS
IN MAKING SURE THAT WERE. ON
SCHEDULE IRRESPECTIVE OF.
THEM BEING DIRECTED OVERSEEN BY
YOU BUT TIED TO THE MITIGATION
EFFORTS ALLEN THE SOLVENCY.
WELL WE WILL HAVE A SECTION IN
THERE. ABOUT LONG RANGE
PLANNING.
AND WHERE WE STAND ON. WATER
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT.
ARE WHERE WE STAND ON OUR.
WATER IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE THAT
AND TRACK THOSE SORT OF
PROJECTS.
LOVE SO START TO TRACK ALTHOUGH
WE HAVEN'T DEVELOPED.
THE PLAN FOR THAT YET BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T GOT TO A POINT WHERE.
HANYA WE'VE BEEN CONCENTRATING
ON THE TEN YEAR PLAN.
WHENEVER WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
WATER EMPLOYER BEFORE WE GO MUCH
FURTHER.
AND THE LONG RANGE PLAN THE
WORLD. WILL TRY TO IDENTIFY AS
MANY OF THOSE PROJECTS AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. MY MY GUT FEEL IS
THAT IT'S GONNA BE.
A SERIES OF PROJECTS MUCH LIKE
WHAT WE HAVE NOW.
TO.
KEEP THE.
A SMALLER BUT SUSTAINABLE
SOLVENCY.
OR IT'S GONNA BE A WATER
IMPORTANT PROJECT.
WHICH ARE VERY EXPENSIVE AND
TAKES A LONG PERIOD OF TIME BUT
CERTAINLY FIXES THE WATER
ELEVATION.
GENTLEMAN.
MY LAST QUESTION AND THEN I'LL
LET MY COLLEAGUE ALSO MAYBE ASK
QUESTIONS SHE STILL DOES IS THE
CURRENT WAY WE'RE DOING THINGS
WORKING.
I MEAN
IS IT WORKING
I THINK IT IS THAT YOU KNOW I
THINK FROM WHERE WE WERE.
TWO YEARS AGO TILL NOW.
DOESN'T SHOW IT ON THE GROUND
BUT I THINK WE HAVE. MADE SOME
GREAT STRIDES INTERNALLY AND
GETTING PLANNING DONE.
INTERNALLY AND GETTING.
.
THE CONSTRUCT OF THE CONTRACTING
PROCESS CORD AROUND HIS SEMI
SAN.
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE MADE
PROGRESS.
WE ARE.
CLOSE AS YOU HEARD EARLIER TO
PUTTING STUFF ON THE GROUND.
AND ONCE WE GET STARTED PUTTING
STUFF ON THE GROUND THAT WILL GO
MUCH QUICKER.
SO YES I THINK IT'S WORKING
COULDN'T STAND IMPROVEMENT IT
SURE COULD.
PERHAPS A THAT THE NEXT JOB I
CAN TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
IMPROVEMENT.
HAVE BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S PART
OF WHAT I'M HOPING WE CAN WALK
AWAY WITH IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE
THE THAT EFFICIENCIES THAT WE
CAN. PUT IN PLACE ARE
CONSIDERING OF THE LONGEVITY OF
THE DISCUSSIONS WE'VE BEEN
HAVING TO TRY TO GET ONE PROJECT
UP THE GROUND.
SURE.
BICU A FEW TIMES I'VE HEARD.
YOU KNOW THE PROCESS IS THE
PROCESS THAT WHO CREATES THE
PROCESS.
I'D THE BOW CONTRACTING PROFITS
WHO CREATES ALL OF THESE
PROCESSES IF WE HAVE IF WE
CREATE THEM THAT WE CAN'T
COMPLAIN ABOUT THEM. BEING SO
LONG AND ARDUOUS.
AND SO IF YOU HAVE ANY ANY SAY
SO IN THE PROCESS THEN IF WE
CREATED THAT WE CAN COMPLAIN
ABOUT HOW HARD IT IS.
THEN WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS.
STREAMLINED THAT PROCESS AND
THAT'S THE FRUSTRATION I HEAR
THAT THIS IS THE FIFTH SIXTH
TIME THAT I HEAR ALL THE PROCESS
THE PROCESS BUT WE CREATE THE
PROCESS.
SO IF WE CREATE PROCESS WE CAN'T
MISS ARE THE COMPLAIN ABOUT HOW
HARD IT IS BECAUSE WE'RE
CREATING IT AND IF WE DO CREATE
PROCESS THAN. HOW ABOUT WE WORK
ON STREAMLINING THE PROCESS SO
THAT WE DON'T WE'RE NOT SITTING
HERE? YOU KNOW GOING ROUND AND
ROUND ABOUT HOW HARD PROCESSES.
WELL I THINK THAT ONE OF MATT'S
NUMBER ONE GOALS.
HIS TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
THAT'S WHY HE'S FAIRLY NEW IN
THAT POSITION.
LESS THAN A MONTH.
AND.
HELLO ALREADY WERE SAYING SOUND
RESULTS BUT HE'S GONNA SEE HOW
MUCH OF THAT.
HIS CHEST INTERNAL PROCESS THAT
CAN BE CLEARED OUT OF THE WAY
SOME OF IT ISN'T PUT THEM. THEIR
MERRY LA MAY BE PARTS OF IT THAT
WE CAN SAY.
WE DON'T NEED TO DO THAT FOR
THESE PROJECTS AND CUT THAT TIME
FRAME ALL.
THERE IS CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY
AND CONSTRUCTION RULES BUT THE
STATE HAS ESTABLISHED FOR GOING
OUT THE CONTRACT. AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT.
IT IS WITHIN THE CONTROL TO
MODIFY OF THE LEGISLATURE.
.
WE FOLLOW PROCESSES THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN STATE. RULES AND
REGULATIONS AUTHORITIES FOR
CONTRACTING UP CONSTRUCTION
SO.
IS THEY'RE EFFICIENCIES THAT
COULD BE. CREATED THEIR TO
SHORTENED TIME FRAMES FORCE
SOMETHING MAYBE. ARM.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT THE DESIGN
BUILD PROCESS IS BRAND NEW.
THERE IS A STEEP LEARNING CURVE
FOR OUR DEPARTMENT TO FIGURE
THAT OUT WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
NOT JUST A CONGRADULATIONS HERE
GO DO THIS. WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THAT PROCESS LOOKS LIKE
WE ARE MAKING GOOD STRIDES IN
THAT.
AND I THINK ONCE WE ESTABLISH
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IT WILL
FACILITATE.
MOVING CONSTRUCTION FORWARD MUCH
MORE QUICKLY THAN AS A QUESTION
ON THAT WE WE HAVE SOME
PARTNERS.
THAT THAT ARE PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION THAT KNOW HOW TO DO
THE DESIGN BUILD ALREADY RIGHT
AND SO WHAT'S IN THE WAY OF
ALLOWING ONE OF THOSE PARTNERS
TO ACTUALLY TAKE THE LEAD ON
THAT PARTICULAR PART OF. WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY WR IS THE
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY OKAY OR
THE STATE PALM? AND IT'S BRAND
NEW AUTHORITY FOR US AND WE'RE
USING AND LEVERAGING CALTRANS.
WHO HAS THAT AUTHORITY ALREADY
NOW SPECIFICALLY DID UP BR WAS
ONLY GIVEN THAT AUTHORITY FOR
CONSTRUCTION AT THE SALTON SEA?
SO WE DIDN'T HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE
NAM AND IN TERMS OF HOW QUICKLY
WE CAN GET THAT AND PLAY THAT'S
WHAT BRUCE IS REFERRING TO AND.
OUR INTERNAL PROCESSES FOR NEW.
TEACHING LEARNING ARE. AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT TAKES TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN INSIDE OF OUR
DEPARTMENT. UPSTART DIVISION OF
ENGINEERING IS. DEDICATED TO
TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT. OF
THEM.
CAN THERE BE EXTRA EMPHASIS
PLACED ON IT I THINK THAT WOULD
BE.
WHO FAIR ENOUGH FOR THE
LEGISLATION A LEGISLATOR HERE
TO?
HOUSE THE DEPARTMENT.
WHAT IS IT THAT WE CAN DO TO
FACILITATE MOVING THESE THINGS
FORWARD? COM ADDITIONAL STAFF
CERTAINLY.
WOULD ASSIST AS YOU IDENTIFIED
OR A BILL IS A BIG BURDEN
THERE'S PLENTY OF OTHER PROJECTS
THAT OUR DIVISION ENGINEERING IS
ALSO COMMITTED TO. SO THEY'RE
BEING STRETCHED IN TERMS OF HOW
MUCH.
OF FOCUS AND PEOPLE THEY CAN
THROW AT IT. AS WELL AS OURS
AGAIN THE DESIGN BUILD IS GONNA
BE A A A WAY THAT WE CAN
LEVERAGE.
CONSULTING FIRMS AND DESIGN
FIRMS SO THAT IT'S NOT JUST
STATE STAFF TRYING TO DO ALL THE
DESIGN WORK AND AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO.
HOMICIDE DO THINK THAT WILL
YOU'LL SEE.
US BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD.
MUCH QUICKER WHEN WE GET THAT.
OVER THAT LEARNING CURVE AND AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT TAKES TO
ESTABLISH THAT AND THEN LET ME
ADD THAT I DON'T THINK AT LEAST
RIGHT NOW. THAT STAFF IS THE
PROBLEM AND.
AND LEARNING THE.
AND DEVELOPING THE DESIGN BILL
THAT'S TRUE THAT'S THAT'S OUR
EXISTING STAFF LEARNING AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT TAKES TO
MAKE THIS PROCESS DESIGN BUILD
PROCESS BUILT INTO THAT
APARTMENT. SO THAT'S NOT AN
ADDITIONAL STAFF WHEN WE GET THE
CONSTRUCTION AND DESIGN AND
OVERSIGHT.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GONNA NEED
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE TO HELP
OVERSEE MULTIPLE CONTRACTORS AND
MAKE THAT MAKE SURE THOSE
PROCESSES.
AND THE CONSTRUCTION HAPPENS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
WE GET THERE.
RIGHT SCOTT LIKE TO CLOSE WITH I
THINK I KNOW YOU'RE LEAVING BUT
THE.
OTHERS.
YEAH I GUESS SO TO SAY.
.
WHO WE'RE PREPARED TO IMPLEMENT
THE FISH WILDLIFE MEASURES ONCE
PROJECTS GET BUILT WE WE WANT
THE FIRST ONE TO GET DONE IT'S
IT'S THE PROOF OF CONCEPT FOR
HOW WE LOOK AT ALL OF THE OTHER
PROJECTS THAT WE'VE GIVEN? OUR
DESIGN INPUT INTO ALL OF THAT.
I THINK AS WE'VE DISCUSSED TODAY
YOU POINTED OUT WE JUST NEED TO
GET THE EASEMENT DOWN.
WE NEED TO GET.
THE CONTRACTING DOWN AND BUILD
THE PROJECT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL WORKING
ON.
RIGHT.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME I APPRECIATE THE.
CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE JUST
HAD I THINK THERE'S SOME
EXPECTATIONS THAT YOU'VE ALSO
PUT FORWARD. IN TERMS OF.
.
MEETING SOME BENCHMARKS.
AND TOUGH FOR US IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'VE GOT A COUPLE THINGS TO
TAKE A LOOK AT AS WELL TO SEE
HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO
REINFORCE.
AND SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS.
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THIS
PROJECT THAT AS MANY OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WE UNDERTAKE THAT
WHETHER BE IT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH WILDLIFE FOR. APARTMENT
WATER RESOURCES IS BEING. LOOKED
AT.
IN THE SAME LEVEL OF PRIORITIES.
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
PROJECTS LIKE THE OROVILLE DAM
PROJECT THAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
TO THE WATER SYSTEM OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE AND AS WAS
HIGHLIGHTED AT THE INTRODUCTION
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. ARE NOT
JUST DO IT REGION'S QUALITY OF
LIFE
I AND OR THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF FOLKS BUT TO THE
ECOSYSTEM. FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
AND SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR. ALL
YOUR TIME IN WILL CALL UP THE
THIRD PANEL THROUGH REAL QUICKLY
WHAT WE CAN DO IS OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT.
BY THE END OF MAY.
PUT TOGETHER WHAT WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DO TO HELP US
NOW.
HA AND I'M.
AND WE CAN MEET WITH YOU GUYS
YES WE CERTAINLY WE CERTAINLY
WILL BE MEETING AND THAT WE WILL
HAVE OUR TEAM HERE. ENGAGE WITH
YOU INTIMATELY EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE ARE ON TRACK
IRRESPECTIVE OF HAVING A HEARING
OR NOT LET ME WE KNOW WHY
BRADLEY PART OF THE TEAM. THANK
YOU THANKS.
WE'LL ASK GOD DAVID DEAD LOW
DISTANCE PROFESSOR OF BIO
MEDICINE AND SCIENCES FROM THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LEASE OR METAL CAN DIRECTOR OF
GLOOMY DISCIPLINE BY IT AND PHIL
ROSEN TRADER.
AT THE CHEN MANAGER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SONGS HERE THORNY.
ALONG WITH CITY UP PASSED
DIRECTOR BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES EASTERN COACHELLA
VALLEY.
WE'LL LET TAKE A TESTIMONY IN
THAT SAME ORDER.
A WELCOME EVERYONE.
COOL.
ALRIGHT YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE ALL
GOT ABOUT. THREE TO FOUR MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY AND.
WE CERTAINLY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AS WELL FOR YOU ALL IN
AND PERHAPS THE.
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
CONVERSATION WE JUST HAD.
HOPING THAT WE COULDN'T ENTER
INTO DIALOGUE AYE WITH EACH ONE
OF YOU THERE'S WELL SO WELCOME
DOCTOR IN KNOW YOU MAY PROCEED
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA'S NEWEST
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
I'M DAVID LOW I MEAN THE THING
IS PROFESSOR OF BIOMEDICAL
SCIENCES AND SEE YOURSELF
FITTING OF RESEARCH FOR THE UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
I'M ALSO DIRECTOR OF THE BRIEF
CENTER AT YOU SEE OUR. BRIEF
STANDS FOR BRIDGING REGIONAL
ECOLOGY ARIS LIGHT TOXINS AND
HEALTH EFFECTS WITCHES. IN BRIEF
A CENTER DEVOTED TO STUDYING AIR
QUALITY AND HEALTH EFFECTS.
THE MULTI DISCIPLINARY CENTER
THAT BRINGS TOGETHER RESEARCHERS
IN ECOLOGY ENVIRONMENTAL HISTORY
CLIMATE MODELING.
AS AND FINALLY TOM HEALTH
EFFECTS.
SO TODAY I'LL BE DISCUSSING
EFFECTS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
EXPOSURES MAINLY THE ONGOING AND
POTENTIAL FUTURE IMPACT OF THE
SALTON SEA ON THE POOR AIR
QUALITY. AND ITS EFFECTS ON
HEALTH IN THE REGION.
SALTON SEA IS ALREADY.
KNOWN TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON
HEALTH THE COACHELLA VALLEY. ON
HEALTH ASSESSMENT SURVEYS HAVE
FOUND THAT IN THE REGION AROUND
THE SALTON SEA ASTHMA RATES ARE
CONSIDERABLY HIGHER THAN
SOMEPLACE APPROACHING DOUBLE THE
RATE IN CALIFORNIA IN GENERAL.
I DON'T HAVE TIME TO DISCUSS
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THESE
HEALTH EFFECTS BUT BE ASSURED
THAT. CHRONIC ILLNESSES RELATED
TO THESE ENVIRONMENTAL EXPOSURES
HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT ON QUALITY
OF LIFE AND DAYS OF WORK LOS
ILLEGALS CERTAINLY INCREASE IF
THE SOUND SEEMED FIREMAN
DEGRADES FURTHER.
IT SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE THAT
LUNG DISEASE THAT STRONGLY
INFLUENCED BY THE QUALITY OF THE
AIR THAT WE BREATHE. UP WE IN
THE MEDICAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNITY HAVE BEEN WELL AWARE
OF THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
POLLUTION AND HEALTH.
INCLUDING LONG AND
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE AND
GENERAL FACTS ON HOW.
BUT IT'S ALSO EVIDENT THAT
POLLUTION IS NOT THE ONLY
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE AFFECTING
HEALTH.
WHAT POLLUTION HAS BEEN STEADILY
DECREASING IN AMERICAN CITIES
THERE'S A NAGGING STATISTIC THAT
ASPIRATE CONTINUE TO INCREASE?
SUGGESTING THAT WE HAVEN'T
COMPLETELY IDENTIFY ALL THE
RELEVANT FACTORS AFFECTING
PULMONARY AND CARDIOVASCULAR
HEALTH.
SO ONE DEVELOPMENT AREA OF STUDY
IS THE HEALTH EFFECTS OF
PARTICULATE MATTER IN THE AIR.
.
AND IT'S IMPACT ON HEALTH. ONE
MAJOR INDICATOR OF OF VERY SMALL
AEROSOL PARTICULATES IS CALLED
PM TEN. WHICH IS THE AMOUNT OF
MATERIAL THE AIR LESS THAN TEN
MICRONS IN SIZE.
SO FOR REFERENCE OF TEN MICRONS
IS LESS THAN A TENTH OF THE
AVERAGE HUMAN HERE. IN AND. WITH
AND LESS THAN HALF THE SIZE OF
TYPICAL POLLEN GRAINS.
THE PARTICLE SIZES MOST RELEVANT
BECAUSE HE'S EXTREMELY SMALL
PARTICLES ARE ABLE PENETRATE
DEEP INTO THE LUNG TISSUE. AND
TRIGGER INFLAMMATORY RESPONSES.
STUDIES THAT PREVIOUSLY SHOWN
THAT IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN
AVERAGE NUMBER OF DEATHS OR
EXCESS DEATHS.
FROM PULMONARY OR CARDIOVASCULAR
CAUSES HAVE OCCURRED IN THE FOUR
DAYS FOLLOWING DUST STORM WITH
HIGH LEVELS OF PM TEN.
THESE WOULD BE CONSIDERED ACUTE
EFFECTS
BUT IS AFFECTED OCCUR QUITE SOON
AFTER EXPOSURE IN CONTRAST TO
CHRONIC EFFECTS WHICH TAKE YEARS
TO DEVELOP.
THESE ACUTE EFFECTS ONLY BEGIN
TO POINT OUT THE EFFECTS OF LOW
DOSE CHRONIC EXPOSURES ON
CHRONIC INFLAMMATORY DISEASES
INCLUDING ASTHMA AND COPD.
SO IT'S ALREADY EVIDENT THAT
AEROSOL PARTICULAR THROUGH
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED HEALTH
RISKS.
NOTE ALSO THAT CHRONIC DISEASES
SUCH AS ASTHMA DO NOT HAVE
SIMPLE CURES.
THESE ARE CHRONIC DISEASES THAT
GET PROGRESSIVELY WORSE OVER
TIME.
SO THERE MEDICAL AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS STAYS WITH US IN THE
LONG TERM.
IN THE STUDIES OF COACHELLA
VALLEY DUST TO DUST STORMS THAT
I MENTIONED.
SPECIFIC COMPONENTS OF THE DUST
CONTRIBUTING TO THE FACTS HAVE
NOT YET BEEN ANALYZED.
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE SALTON SEA
HOWEVER THE COMPONENTS OF THE
DUST ARE RELEVANT.
AT THE EXPOSED LAKE BED THE AT
THE PLAYA TOXIC MATERIALS ARE
CONCENTRATED AND EXPOSED.
THE TOXIC MATERIALS INCLUDE
HEAVY METALS SUCH AS SELENIUM
PESTICIDES SUCH AS DDT FROM
AGRICULTURAL RUNOFF. AND OTHER
TOXIC ORGANIC COMPOUNDS PRODUCED
IN THE WATER.
SOILS IN THE REGION ALSO CONTAIN
BACTERIA AND FUNGI THAT A PART
OF THE ENVIRONMENTALLY COLLEGE
YOU THE REGION. YOU NO DOUBT
AWARE OF THE IMPACT OF THE SOIL
FUNGAL MICRO. TECH STUDIO.
EXCIDIO EIGHTIES IN THE. CAUSE
OF VALLEY FEVER.
WANT WHEN I BEGAN THIS
DISCUSSION WITH REFERENCE TO
CHRONIC PULMONARY DISEASE SUCH
AS ASTHMA AND CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASES AS WELL AS INFECTIOUS
DISEASES.
I SHOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT
INCREASED AEROSOL PARTICULATES
ARE ALSO INSISTED WITH SYSTEMIC
DISEASES INCLUDING NARROW
DEVELOPMENTAL DISEASES SUCH
OUGHT SUCH AS AUTISM. AND NEURO
DEGENERATIVE DISEASES SUCH AS
ALZHEIMER'S AND PARKINSON'S.
THESE EFFECTS SIMPLY POINT TO
THE OVERALL GENERAL HEALTH
IMPACT OF DEGRADED AIR QUALITY.
EVEN WITHOUT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
VEHICLE EMISSIONS AT.
POLLUTANTS.
SO HOW MUCH DOES THE DRYING
SOLVENCY CONTRIBUTE TO THESE
ARIS LIGHT PARTICULATES IN
COACHELLA VALLEY.
A RECENT STUDY BY ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES WRITE A BAHRAINI AT
UC RIVERSIDE.
HAS EXAMINED THE THE AEROSOL
DUST IN THE VALLEY AND FOUND
THAT AS MUCH AS SEVENTY PERCENT
OF CERTAIN COMPONENTS OF THE
DUST ORIGINATE FROM THE EXPOS
PLY AT THE SALTON SEA.
SO IT'S THE PHONE THING DRIES UP
DUE TO REDUCED INPUT FROM
AGRICULTURAL RUNOFF THESE PLAYA
DUST WILL NOT ONLY COMPRISE A
GREATER PROPORTION OF THE
AEROSOL PARTICULATE. BUT WILL
ALSO INCREASE THE OVERALL
CONCENTRATION OF PARTICULATES IN
THE VALLEY.
THIS NOT ONLY NARAL CONCERN TO
THE PEOPLE LIVING RIGHT NEXT TO
SALTON SEA.
THE EFFECTS OF THE ARE SLICE
PARTICLES ALREADY EXTEND WELL
ACROSS THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
BEYOND THE SHORT SO THE SALTON
SEA.
PARTICLE TRANSPORTER NELSON BY
ANOTHER ON TO MY COLLEAGUES.
THAT YOU SEE ARE WILL PORTER
SURE THAT PARTICLE TRANSPORT BY
SEASONAL WINS.
CARRY HIGH CONCENTRATIONS OF THE
US TO THE SOUTH AND EASTERN THE
WINTER AND SPRING MONTHS.
BUT DURING THE SUMMER AND FALL
MONTHS THE WINDS ALSO CARRY
PARTICLES NORTH AND WEST WHERE
THE CITIES OF PALM DESERT IN
PALM SPRINGS ARE AFFECTED.
THE SULFURIC ODORS EMITTED BY
THAT YEAR CHEMISTRY OF THE
SALTON SEA ARE ALREADY FAMILIAR
TO RESIDENTS OF RESIDENTS OF
PALM SPRINGS.
AND HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO DRIFT
AS FAR AS ORANGE AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES WHEN THE
WINDS ARE JUST RIGHT.
SO IT SHOULD BE NO COMFORT TO
KNOW THAT INCREASING LEVELS OF
PM TEN PARTICULATES AND THEIR
HEALTH IMPACTS ARE ON THEIR WAY
AS WELL.
SO MANY OF OTHERS HAVE ALREADY
FOR TO THE CRISIS OF THE SALTON
SEA OR RATHER MULTIPLE CRISES IN
TERMS OF INCREASING SALINITY AND
EFFECT ON WATER QUALITY AQUATIC
LIFE MIGRATORY BIRD POPULATIONS.
AS WELL AS IMPACT FUND TURRETS
AND AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY.
I'M HERE TO POINT TO THE CRISIS
AND HEALTH EFFECTS THROUGHOUT
THE REGION THAT'S ALREADY IN
PROGRESS.
AND THE TRENDS POINT TO
INCREASINGLY SEVERE EFFECTS IN
PULMONARY AND CARDIOVASCULAR
HEALTH WITH INCREASING IMPACTS
AND OTHER CHRONIC DISEASES AS
WELL.
WHILE THE BRIEF CENTER YOU SEE
OUR RESEARCH IS FOCUS ON
UNDERSTANDING FROM THE DETAILED
MECHANISM.
BEHIND THESE HEALTH IMPACTS.
UP MUCH OF THE EVIDENCE AND
ASSOCIATIONS ARE ALREADY KNOWN
AS I MENTIONED.
OTHERS ARE ABLE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THE SCALE OF ECONOMIC AND
POPULATION AFFECTS.
AND MEMBER OF THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY WE HELPED TO PROVIDE A
WARNING ON THE SEVERITY OF THE
INCREASING HEALTH EFFECTS AND
ACCOMPANYING ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
IMPACTS INSOLVENCY.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME AND TOUCH
THANK YOU DOCTOR AT THE NEXT UP
PRESENTER WILL BE DUDLEY SO
MOTHER WITHOUT ME TO SIMPLIFY.
THINK OF IT THANK CHAIRMAN.
FINANCIALLY SO MELLOW AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COMMITTEES
TO EQUAL BY A WHERE A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION.
BUT ARE PRIMARY FOCUS ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THE SALTON SEA PERSIST IN THE
BURDENS OF POLLUTION FAILING TO
MEET FEDERAL STANDARDS FOR
PARTICULATE MATTER.
LONG BEFORE THE SALTON SEA
BECAME A CBO PM ANTARCTIC'S
PROBLEM IN OUR REGION.
WITH AS MUCH AT ALL TIME HIGH
CARDIOVASCULAR AND RESPIRATORY
PROBLEMS IN THE REGION NEED
SWIFT.
IMPLEMENTATION OF MITIGATION
PROJECTS
TO STABILIZE THE MISSIVE OF
CONDITIONS.
OUR BOYS TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
FOR THIS REASON COMEY BESSIE
BECAUSE BY IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF. WATER
RESOURCES LAUNCH THE SALTON SEA
COMMUNITY OUTREACH EDUCATION AND
ENGAGEMENT PROGRAM WE CALL
CHLOE.
THE EDUCATION.
GET COMMUNITY INVOLVED. ENGAGE
THE COMMUNITY IN THE EXISTING
CONDITIONS AND PROGRESS OF THE
TEN YEAR PLAN.
WE HAVE DEVELOPED EDUCATION
MATERIALS THAT IS CLEARLY
COMPREHENSIBLE TO THE COMMUNITY
INTO PREDOMINANT LANGUAGE IS
ENGLISH AND SPANISH. EXPLAINING
TO THE COMMUNITY AS CLEAR AND
SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE GENERAL
INFORMATION ON THE SALTON SEA.
ITS HISTORY ITS CURRENT
CONDITIONS HOW IT AFFECTS
WILDLIFE HABITAT PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND THE SALTON SEA REPRESENTS
WHAT'S TAUGHT AND HE REPRESENTS
TO THE COMMUNITY.
THE AVERAGE INFORMATION PROVIDED
TO THE COMMUNITY INCLUDES AIR
MONITORING INFORMATION FOUND
THAT I'VE BEEN THERE DOT ORG.
CONSISTING OF FORTY LOW COST
MONITORS COLOCATED TO AYE A DE
REGULATORY MONITORING STATIONS
AND DISTRIBUTED. USING
REGULATORY AND SCIENTIFIC
METHODOLOGIES.
THE COMMUNITY AIR MONITORING
INFORMATION IS ONE OF THE FIRST
TOOLS THAT WE USE TO DEVELOP A
COMMUNICATIONS PLAN ON THE
HEALTH HAZARDS OF THE SALTON
SEA.
THE ISLAND AIRPORT ON IS A TOOL
THAT CAN BE USED BY INDIVIDUALS
TO FIND AIR QUALITY REAL TIME
AIR QUALITY IN THE AREAS OF THE
SALTON SEA. THREE WEB ORDER THAT
OR THAT IT THAT ALSO PROVIDES
OUR MERCHANT AND THE COMMUNITY
CAN REGISTER AND SIGN UP TO GET
THESE ALERTS.
WE HAVE INCREASED THE USE OF THE
IVAN AIR BY PROMOTING SCHOOL
FLAT PROGRAM FOR EIGHTEEN
SCHOOLS ARE CURRENTLY.
PARTICIPATING ACTIVELY BY FLYING
A COLOR FLAG DEPENDING ON THE
AIR QUALITY IN EVERY SCHOOL.
DAY TO PROMOTE AIR QUALITY
CONDITIONS
AND RAISE AWARENESS OFTHE START
TO THEIR STUDENTS COMMUNITY AND
THEIR QUALITY. OF UNHEALTHY AIR
QUALITY.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE A TO SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY PARTICIPATING THIS
PROGRAM WOULD BENEFIT ALL
SCHOOLS IN THE SALTON SEA
REGION.
AND THE LEGISLATURE CAN BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN SHIFTING THIS
PROGRAM FROM A VOLUNTARY TO
MANDATORY PROGRAM FOR ALL
SCHOOLS IN THE SALTON SEA
REGION.
WE HAVE SHARED INFORMATION BY
TEN THE LOCAL EVENTS COMMUNITY
HEALTH FAIRS.
SCHOOL PRESENTATIONS PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS AND WORKSHOPS HELD BY
AGENCIES WHERE THE SALTON SEA
AND PUBLIC HEALTH ARE THE MAIN
TOPICS REACHING OVER THREE
THOUSAND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ON
EIGHTEEN PUBLIC EVENTS OVER THE
PAST OUT TWELVE MONTHS.
ACTUALLY DOT THE FIRST YEAR OF
THIS PROGRAM.
WE HAVE RECENTLY STARTED
PROMOTING THE CAMPAIGN IN
TRADITIONAL MEDIA OUR LOCAL A
BECAUSE THAT KNOWN AS ANGELS
WILL BE KNOWN AS WHICH
DISTRIBUTES OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND THREE COPIES. BIKE
WEEKLY TWO THREE HUNDRED NATURE
CHEATED LOCATIONS IN IMPERIAL
VALLEY DEDICATED TRUCK COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT BEFORE MORE
TRADITIONAL MEDIA. WE'VE ALSO
BEEN COMMUNICATING THROUGH.
.
TV MEDIA CAMPAIGNS THAT HAS ALSO
BEEN ONGOING THROUGH COMMUNITY
AT THESE ISSUES A GOOD AYE
INFORMING. SOUTH AND SEE THE
CAMPAIGN.
HAS BEEN RUNNING SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN.
AT SIX TO EIGHT DAILY
APPEARANCES PER STATION IT IS
QUIET RUNNING ON THREE TV
STATIONS AND THAT WE SEE ON FOR
SPANISH IN PERSON IN IMPERIAL
VALLEY.
AND FOR THE ENGLISH VERSION
CHAOS WTA AND IMPERIAL VALLEY.
BANK HERE KATIE FX AND THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WHAT WE PRESENT
AT THE SALTON SEA. CURRENT
SITUATION.
AND THESE EFFORTS WE PUT THE
BLUEPRINTS SALTON SEA.
AND ENGAGE IN OUR COMMUNITY TO
STAY INFORMED AND INVOLVED IN
THIS MAJOR HEALTH ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS OUR COMMUNITY. INCITING
THE COMMUNITY TO OUT AND VISIT
OUR WEBSITE.
ADDITIONAL PARTNERS WORKING WITH
COMIC THIS TYPICAL EMBARKED ON
AIR MONITORING HELD EXPOSURE
ASSESSMENTS AND SALTON SEA
SEDIMENT CHARACTERIZATION
INCLUDE THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
TRACKING CALIFORNIA.
UC DAVIS YOU SEE AS THE AND UCLA
THEY'RE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
US.
ALTHOUGH THERE IS TREMENDOUS
COMBINED EFFORT IN THE REGION TO
RAISE AWARENESS AND ENGAGEMENT
WHICH HAS BEEN HIGHLY
RESPONSIVE.
SO THE REQUEST THAT PUBLIC THIS
HE RECALL MADE CAR. AS AND WE
HAVE OUR MEMBERS THAT THAT WE
ACTUALLY CAME HERE THREE YEARS
AGO.
AND AND MUCH OF LOS EDUCATION
AND CASEMENT.
OF GOALS HAVE HAVE BEEN MET.
THAT TEN YEAR PLAN IS MOVING AT
A MUCH LOWER RATE.
THEN WHAT WE THAN WHAT OUR
COMMUNITY IS DEMANDING.
WE NEED TO SEE ACTION A PERHAPS
AN ACHIEVABLE TIMELINE FOR
PROJECTS.
AND EFFORTS TO HAPPEN AROUND THE
SALTON SEA.
IT IS CRUCIAL TO CONTINUE TO GET
SUPPORT TOWARD PEACE EFFORTS OF
EDUCATING AND INFORMING AND
ENGAGING COMMUNITY ABOUT
CHANGES.
AND IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN THE SALTON SEA. SAW
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE THAT THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN INCREASE
COLLABORATION AMONGST ALL
PARTIES.
LET ME PISSY VEHICLE MEMBERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS.
OUR STAKEHOLDERS AT THE SALTON
SEA REGION AND WE COMMIT TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT COLLABORATION
IN THE AREAS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
THERE IS ALSO A NEED FOR AN
ACCELERATED COLLABORATION TO
FACILITY PERMITTING AND
EASEMENTS.
THAT MAY BE DELAYING PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION AND I WAS
RECENTLY INFORMED THAT. THAT
THESE OBSTACLES ARE GETTING
RESOLVED. WHICH IS PROMISING
PROGRESS.
HISTORY HAS PROVEN THAT WE
CANNOT TAKE FOCUS OFF.
A MAINTAINING A PRIOR IT
TAXATION OF THE MOST URGENT
STABILISATION PROJECTS.
THAT.
THAT ONCE THE STABILIZE
WANT TO SEE IT STABILIZE AT THE
MOST THE MISSIVE EXPOSED AREA.
THEN WE CAN HAVE POSITIVE A BACK
IN DRIVING INVESTOR CONFIDENCE
FOR DEVELOPMENT AND TOURISM
WHICH CAN FURTHER REVITALIZED
THE SALTON SEA REGION.
ALL PROJECTS SHOULD ADDRESS BUT
NOT LIMITED TO WILDLIFE HABITAT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AS MEASURES OF SUCCESS.
NATURAL RESOURCE IS AGENCY NEEDS
A DIRECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADOPT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH POLICIES TO BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED WITHIN ITS
AGENCY PROGRAMS AND DEPARTMENTS.
BRUCE WILCOX THE SUFFICIENT
STAFF.
THAT NEEDS TO BE ASSIGNED TO THE
SALTON SEA.
I KNOW THIS IS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE PORCH JUST
MADE A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
PURSUANT AB SIX SEVENTEEN. SO
WHEN AGENCIES ARE WILLING TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS THERE IS EVIDENCE
THEY CAN MAKE IT HAPPEN.
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING INSIGHT.
IT'S ALSO A GOOD TIME TO REVISIT
THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
ONE THAT IS EFFICIENT AND. CAN
DELIVER.
GOOD OUTCOMES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY.
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
PHIL ROSENTRADERS SERVICE THE
GENERAL MANAGER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE SALTON SEA
AUTHORITY.
WE ARE A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
THAT IS EMPOWERED TO ENGAGE IN
REVITALIZATION EFFORTS AT THE
SALTON SEA WERECOMPRISED OF THE
ESSENTIAL LOCAL ENTITIES AROUND
THE SEE THAT HAVE. LAND USE
JURISDICTION WATER RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT.
YEAH AND PROPERTY OWNERSHIP THE
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENTS YOU WANT
TO HAVE AT THE TABLE FOR GOING
TO FASHION REALISTIC FEASIBLE
SOLUTIONS.
THAT JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY HAS
BEEN ENGAGE IN A.
HIGHLY PRODUCTIVE WAY WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN FACT WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS
BUT A LOT OF TALK ABOUT DELAYS
AND.
.
OF THE IMPLICATIONS OF A DO
NOTHING SCENARIO THAT DO NOTHING
SCENARIO WHICH COULD BE
DEVASTATING ON OUR ECOSYSTEM
ARE.
HUMAN HEALTH IMPACTS OUR
HABITAT.
AND IT COULD ALSO DESTROY OUR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES THE
LOCALS UNDERSTAND THIS BETTER
THAN ANYONE ELSE BECAUSE WE ARE
THE ONES WHO WILL SUFFER IF
NOTHING IS DONE.
WE TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY WEAR
THE. I WOULD ARGUE THE MOST
HIGHLY MOTIVATED OF ANYONE YOU
WILL FIND AROUND THE SALTON SEA
IN ANY OF THESE DISCUSSIONS. AND
THAT IS WHY WE ARE MAKING
PROGRESS THE LOCALS DROVE THE
INITIATIVE THE LOCALS CAME UP
THE UNDER CONTRACT WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THE SALTON SEA
AUTHORITY PRODUCED A FINANCIAL
FEASIBILITY ACTION PLAN. ON TIME
ON BUDGET.
LET ME REPEAT ON TIME ON BUDGET
THESE ARE LOCALS
UNDER WORKING TOGETHER UNIFIED.
A SENSE OF WITH THE SALT SEA AT
THE ALREADY. IN COOPERATION WITH
THE STATE WE PRODUCE SOMETHING
THAT WAS VALUABLE THAT SERVES AS
THE FOUNDATION OF THE SALT SEA
MANAGEMENT PLAN. THAT IS A MODEL
THAT HAS WORKED AND I SUBMIT TO
YOU SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AS.
PART OF THE SOLUTION MOVING
FORWARD HAD WE KEEP THINGS ON
TRACK LET'S LOOK AT WHAT WORKS
WHAT HAS WORKED.
AND WHAT IS CONTINUING TO WORK
OH I SUBMITTED SOME WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. PER REQUEST FROM THE
CHAIR THAT WILL GO INTO ALL THE
DETAILS CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
READ IT IN THE INTEREST TIME.
BUT LET ME CUT TO THE CHASE WITH
THE LOCALS LEAD WE ALL SUCCEED
AN EXAMPLE THIS IN RECENT MEMORY
THE LAST MONTH. THE LOCALS WITH
THE SALT SEA AUTHORITY HAS LEAD
AGENCY UNDER CONTRACT WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
TOWARDS MARTINEZ CAHUILLA DESERT
TRIBE.
PLEADED THE FIRST PHASE OF THE
TOWARDS MARTINEZ WETLANDS
PROJECT.
THIS IS THE FIRST STATE FUNDED
PROJECT EVER COMPLETED AT THE
SALTON SEA.
WHILE IT IS SMALL IT IS
CERTAINLY OF MONUMENTAL IN THE
FACT IT IS BEGINNING OF FIRST
TANGIBLE STEP.
TOWARD WHAT MUST HAPPEN A
THOUSAND TIMES OVER.
NOW WE HAVE THE MEANS WE HAVE
THE CAPABILITY THE COMPETENCY OF
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
TO DELIVER ON TIME ON BUDGET AS
THAT PROJECT WAS AS WELL IS THE
FINANCIAL FEASIBILITY ACTION
PLAN I MENTIONED EARLIER.
SO WE HAVE THE MOTIVATION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN CONCERT.
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE STATE
AND I THINK THAT IS THE KEY
WORKING THE LOCALS INTO A SENSE
OF WHAT THE STATE OF HOW WE GET
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON BOARD.
NONE OF THIS WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
IF THE LOCALS HAD NOT SET ASIDE
DIFFERENCES.
LONG YEARS AGO THAT SEPARATED
THEM AND DID NOT ALLOW THEM TO
MOVE FORWARD AND UNIFIED FASHION
ON PLANS AND PROJECTS.
AND IT AT A UNITED EFFORT
APPEARS SACRAMENTO AND BACK IN
DC
WHAT THE LOCALS CAME TOGETHER WE
STARTED TO SEE PROGRESS.
THEY AGREED THAT THEY SHOULD
ESTHER LOCAL LEADERSHIP.
AND WITHOUT THAT IF WE JUST
CONTINUE TO GO DOWN THE PATH OF
TRUSTING THE STATE TO MOVE. AND
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
OF LOCAL FRANKLY HAD VERY LITTLE
FAITH THAT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN ANYTHING PRODUCTIVE.
THE LOCALS DECIDED THEY WOULD.
OF ADOPT A SET OF GUIDING
PRINCIPLE THE SOLVENCY OF THE
WORD HE HAS THREE GETTING
PRINCIPLES
A CERTAIN LOCAL. LEADERSHIP
WHICH WE HAVE DONE AND WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED.
SECOND.
LET'S HAVE MULTIPLE BENEFITS OUT
OF EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE CHALLENGES
LET'S MAKE SURE THOSE CHALLENGES
ARE INTEGRATED THE PLANNING WAY
THE STATE HAS DONE THIS THEY ARE
UNDER IT LEGAL OBLIGATION TO DO
THIS.
IN FACT TO A DUSTY HABITAT
AND THE HUMAN HEALTH CONDITIONS.
THE LOCAL WOULD LIKE TO SEE
OPPORTUNITIES IN ECONOMIC SECTOR
FOR RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
RECREATION INCORPORATED BECAUSE
THAT IS THE. MEANS WERE TALK
ABOUT FUNDING IN IMPLEMENTATION.
HOW DO WE SET UP GOVERNMENT'S
WORKS WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT
HOW WE SET UP FUNDING MECHANISMS
AT WORK AND? THE LOCALS AND THE
SALT SEA THOR IN OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS.
HAVE.
ESTABLISH THAT AS PART OF OUR
GUIDING PRINCIPLE THE THIRD IS
IF WE DEVELOP THESE RESOURCES
LOCALLY WILL MAKE SURE. THAT
THERE IS A IF THERE.
CONTROLLED ERROR ON PUBLIC LAND
ROB DIBBLE PUBLIC RESOURCES THAT
THEY BRING THE PUBLIC BENEFIT
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY AND ARE
VESTED. IN THE LONG TERM
SOLUTION THAT THE C. RATHER
EXTRACTED AND.
REDIRECTED ELSEWHERE.
WE HAVE.
SEATED ON A VERY SMALL SCALE WE
A. FIRST STEP IT'S BEEN
COMPLETED WE HAVE LONG WAY TO GO
BUT THAT JOURNEY OF A THOUSAND
MILES BEGINS WITH THAT FIRST
STEP AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY.
THE CELL SEE AUTHORITY AND ITS
LOCAL PARTNERS WORKING WITH THE
STATE. HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL WE
NEED TO CONTINUE THAT UPWARD
TRAJECTORY.
I OF WHAT YOUR QUESTION
PATRICIA.
I THINK YOU.
TEMMINCK I SEE.
AS SO FIRST I FILLED UP US ON
THE DIRECTOR OF BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES SAN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY. AND IT BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES WHERE COMPOSED OF
VARIOUS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
AND RESIDENTS WHO WORK TOGETHER
AND SEEK.
POLICY AND SYSTEM SOLUTION THAT
ARE GOING TO ADDRESS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR REGION.
IN OUR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
WORK WE ACCOUNT WITH THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF OUR TEAM WITH
CONCRETE DESIGN INITIATIVE ON SO
THEY'RE DESIGNERS AND PLANNERS
ON CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
RURAL STUDIES.
COACHELLA UNINCORPORATED YOUTH
MEDIUM.
TOM AUDUBON.
I LOW MULLIN THE UNIVERSITY AND
I'M SIERRA CLUB SO WE BELIEVE
THAT HAVE THAT THE GROUP THAT WE
HAVE REALLY BRINGS THE EXPERTISE
ALONG WITH THE RESIDENTS. TO
COME UP WITH SOME SOLUTIONS THAT
OUR.
.
THAT ARE GOING TO ADDRESS
INITIAL HOLISTICALLY AND.
GREEN REALLY THE TYPES OF NEEDS
THAT WE NEED TO SEE A
CONSULTANCY.
SO I'VE FOUGHT YOU HAVE A
PRESENTATION IN FRONT OF YOU
I'VE FOUND IT. DIVIDED INTO FOUR
MAJOR.
TALKING POINTS ONE OF THEM I'M
GOING TO START BY TALKING ABOUT
THE GAPS WITHIN THE SOLVENCY
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
PARTICULARLY I SAID I'M
PERTAINS TO COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
ON THEN I WILL MOVE AHEAD AND.
PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK FOR A
PARTICIPATORY ENGAGEMENT ON
THEM.
AND DISCUSS SUB POTENTIAL
BENEFITS THAT LUCK.
AT SOLUTIONS BEYOND US
MITIGATION AND.
THEN WE DO PROVIDE SOME REQUEST
OF FOR THE STATE.
SO BRIEFLY TO START ON THE GAPS
WITHIN THE SALTON SEA I'VE BEEN
ON IN EACH AND THE ISSUE OF THE
SALTON SEA SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN WHEN I USED TO WORK ON
FIRE. FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER A
AND ON SINCE THEN UNTIL NOW ONE
OF THE.
MEAN GAPS IN TALKING ABOUT THE
SOUTH AND SEE IF THAT IT'S ON
AGENCY DRIVEN.
AND SO THE PRIORITIES OF THE
AGENCIES COME ON AT THE TOP OF
THE PROCESS BUT THERE'S THE
MISSING COMPONENT OF COMMUNITY
VOIGTS.
IF AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE.
BEAUTIFUL MAP THAT WAS
PRESENTED BY ON THE STATE YOU
VERY ACCURATELY SEE WHY WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE SALTON
SEA YOU SEE HOW RAPIDLY ON THE
SEA IS DECLINING. AND YOU ALSO
SEE WHERE THE PROJECTS ARE GOING
TO BE LOCATED BUT WHAT'S MORE
IMPORTNT IS WHAT YOU DO NOT SEE
ON THAT MATTER. WHAT YOU DO NOT
SEE ON THAT MAP IS HOW CLOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE LEADING TO THE
SALTON SEA? AND TO WHETHER THESE
COMMUNITIES GET TO.
BENEFIT DIRECTLY FROM SOME OF
THE PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED
SO IN THE PRESENTATION IN FRONT
OF YOU.
.
I DID OUT PUT A MAP RIGHT NEXT
TO IT THAT SHOWS. AND.
BREAD AND THE THE REASON THAT
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE RED IS
BECAUSE THEY ARE DEEPLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
YOU.
pTWENTY SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
ARE LIVING IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
THE SEA.
AND THERE ARE OF FOR
COMMUNITIES BONE BY BEACH NORTH
SHORE.
ANON.
ARE THE SALTON SEA AREAWEST
CHOICE AREA THAT REALLY IN THE
TEN YEAR PLAN DO NOT GIVE
ADDRESSED
HOME OUT EXCEPT I SHOULD SAY
THAT THERE ARE SOME RECENT
ATTEMPTS THAT MAYBE ARE NOT
REFLECTED IN THE TEN YEAR PLAN
TO DO SOMETHING IN WEST SHORE
SINCE I'VE HEARD RECENTLY.
I'M SO WHY I'M THAT IS IMPORTANT
WILL IT'S NOT ONLY ON THAT MAP
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK THAT TEN WHEN
YOU READ AT THE.
TEN YEAR PLAN.
YOU ALSO SEE THAT OF ARE
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT REFLECTED IN
THE METHODOLOGIES THAT ARE USED
TO IDENTIFY.
.
PROJECTS.
OR.
.
OR THE LOCATION FOURTHS OF SUCH
PROJECTS SO ON THE TEN YEAR PLAN
STIPULATES THAT THE AIR QUALITY
MITIGATION WILL CONSIST OF
MEASURES TO KEEP EXPOSE PLAYA
WET. OR VEGETATED.
IT ALSO SAYS THAT DETERMINATION
OF PI EMISSIVITY WILL DRIVE THE
LOCATION OF THAT DUST
SUPPRESSION PROJECTS
NEITHER THE PROJECTS WERE
MITIGATING DOES NOR THE CITING
OF THESE PROJECTS TO GIVE SENATE
CONSIDERATION TO IMPROVING
QUALITY OF LIFE.
SO BY OVERLAYING THE CURRENT MAP
WITH THE EXISTING COMMUNITIES I
REALLY THINK THAT ON IT COULD
SERVE THE STATE ASSEMBLY MINDER
THAT THE STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION
THAT'S FAR GREATER THAN ADHERING
TO THE QUANTIFICATION SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. AND THE RECENTLY
AMENDED STIPULATED ORDER THE
STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS ONTO THIS AND.
HEALTH IS TO BE UNDERSTOOD IN
ITS BROAD DEFINITION TO INCLUDE
THE CONDITIONS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTS IN WHICH PEOPLE.
ARE BORN LIVE LEARN WORK PLAY
WORSHIP AND EIGHTEEN SH THAT
AFFECT A WIDE RANGE OF HEALTH
FUNCTIONING AND
SO.
THE PREVIOUS PRESENTATION.
TALKED ABOUT OUTREACH
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
HAS COME A LONG WAYS IN THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO ON TO.
OUTREACH
BUT.
AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL BUT WE
WANT TO SEE IF SINGLE ANCIENT
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT PROCESS.
OUTREACHES WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW WHERE THERE'S A PUBLIC
FORUM.
MAYBE THERE SOME FIRING IN THE
COMMUNITY THEIR SEN FORMATION
GIVEN SIMILAR TO THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS PROVIDED.
.
TO YOU ALL THE AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW AND THEN THE
RESPONSE FROM THE COMMUNITY IS
VERY SIMILAR TO THE RESPONSE
THAT WE SAW ON THE DICE.
THERE'S FRUSTRATION AND THERE'S
REALLY NO VENUE FOR INPUT
NOW WE KNOW THAT.
.
AT THE COMMUNITY ON THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE HAVE IN THE
EASTERN COULD TELL ABOUT THE
IT'S REALLY ARE REGION'S
GREATEST ASSET THEY ARE VERY
ACTIVE IN IMPROVING THEIR OWN
HEALTH AND THAT OF THEIR
NEIGHBORS. WITHIN AN EXTREMELY
RESOURCE LIMITED ENVIRONMENT ON
WORKING IN COLLABORATION WITH
BUILDING HEALTHY COMMUNITIES ON
THE RESIDENTS OF NORTH SHORE
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY WORK TO EXTEND
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO THE
REMOTE COMMUNITY. AND SECURED
AGREEMENTS AMONG SEVERAL
AGENCIES TO BUILD THE PARK.
AND SO AGAIN WE NEED TO START
LOOKING AT OUR COMMUNITIES ASK
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SOMETHING TO
OFFER THEY HAVE THE EXPERTISE
THEY DEAL WITH THE SEA ON A DAY
TO DAY BASIS WE MIGHT NOT BE. OR
THAT TYPICAL PERSON INCLUDING
MYSELF ARE NOT DESIGNERS ARE.
PLANNERS BUT WE UNDERSTAND HOW
TO NAVIGATE OUR COMMUNITY SO I
THINK WORKING WITH THE EXPERTISE
THAT'S PROVIDED BY THE STATE WE
WOULD HAVE A MORE ON HOLISTIC
APPROACH. I'M SO I DO OFFER SOME
KEY CRITERIA.
THAT WE SEE NECESSARY FOR A
TRUE PARTICIPATORY ENGAGEMENT ON
PROCESS AND WE.
FIRST OF ALL IS THAT WE NEED TO
SEE THE PROCESS AS ONE THAT IS
INTEGRATED AND.
AS THE TEN YEAR PLAN HAS
HAPPENED IS THE PLANNING HAPPEN
ON ONE END AND NOW IT'S LIKE
WE'RE BACK PEDALING TO GOING
INFORM THE COMMUNITY WE HAVE
NEVER SAT DOWN TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO. AND
WHAT IS ALL OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND HOW ARE WE
GOING TO REALLY BRING SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE
PEOPLE LIVING NEAR THE SEA.
THANKS AGAIN ONE INTEGRATED
PROCESS
A SECOND AS WE NEED ENGAGE IN
FACILITATION A COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT NEEDS TO BE A TWO WAY
STREET.
.
THIS REQUIRES THE STATE TO BE
WILLING TO LEARN AND KNOW HOW TO
ASK
QUESTIONS AND ENGAGE IN DIALOGUE
THAT COULD INFORM A POSSIBLE
ACTION. THERE NEEDS TO BE
GENUINE INTEREST IN LISTENING TO
AND REFLECTING THE NEEDS THE
CONCERNS THAT DREAMS THAT THIS
COMMUNITY HAS FOR THE SEAT.
ACCESSIBILITY.
FOCUSING ON THE PROCESS ALLOWS
THE MEETINGS WITH THE COMMUNITY
TO BECOME OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS RATHER THAN SIMPLE
TRANSACTION.
TO.
BUILD SOLUTIONS RATHER THAN
BEING ON OPPOSITE ENDS OF WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN OF THE SCENE. AT
THE SCENE.
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO LOOK AS MUCH AS TO WHO
WITHIN THE ROOM. WHERE THE
MEETINGS ARE LOCATED ON HOW THE
INFORMATION IS PRESENTED?
AND THE SPACES NEED TO BE
COMFORTABLE.
FOR RESIDENTS WHERE INFORMAL
ENGAGEMENT AS WELL AS.
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE ARE VALUED AS
MUCH AS THE AGENCY PRESENTATIONS
AND DATE.
AND FINALLY FOR THIS.
PORTION IS THE STATE REALLY
NEEDS TO EMBRACE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCEPT ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE
COMMUNITY.
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS.
THAT WE OWE HERE IN FORUMS IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THE MONEY
HOW IS IT SPENT AND.
I MEAN THE FIRST PRESENTATION
GIVE US VERY GOOD INFORMATION ON
THAT BUT BEYOND THAT I THINK THE
STATE NEEDS TO BE CLEAR AND SET
CLEAR PARAMETERS THAT DEFINE THE
PURPOSE OF COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
AND THE EXPECTED OUTCOMES FROM
IT WHAT IS THE PURPOSE TO ENGAGE
THE COMMUNITY IF OUR INPUT IS AT
THE END WILL NOTBE REFLECTED ON
THE PLAN. AT THAT'S THE KEYS
STONING AGENTS.
THAT AND THEN MOVING ON TO.
.
COLD BENEFITS BEYOND DUST
MITIGATION
SO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THE
TEN YEAR PLAN FAILED TO CONSIDER
HOW ITS HABITAT AND THAT'S
MITIGATION EFFORTS IMPACT
QUALITY OF LIFE. YET THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
CONSIDER THE ACHIEVEMENT OF CO
BENEFITS IN MANAGING THE SALTON
SEA.
RELIEF FOR THE STATE TO US WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO LEVERAGE THE
RESOURCES
ON THAT ARE AVAILABLE THAT THE
STATE AND LOCAL.
AND FEDERAL LEVEL.
DOES STATE NEEDS TO EMBRACE THE
CONCEPT THAT BEYOND MEETING ITS
OBLIGATION TO MITIGATE DOES
STATE CAN ADDRESS EXISTING
COMMUNITY NEEDS THAT IMPROVE
QUALITY OF LIFE.
SO.
AGAIN BUT I AM PERCENT MEAN.
NEXT IS JUST AN IDEA OF WHAT
CALL BENEFITS GIVEN THE
KNOWLEDGE AND THE ENGAGEMENT
THAT MY MY ORGANIZATION DOES.
.
BUT IT IS NOT PRESCRIPTIVE
I'M SO WANT SOME OF THE THINGS
IS THAT WE WANT TO SEE INCREASE
RECREATIONAL SPACE
WE WANT TO SEE IMPROVED ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY PARTICULARLY LOCAL
JOBS.
A CONSERVATION OF THE ECOSYSTEM
PROTECTION FROM INCLEMENT
WEATHER PARTICULARLY DUST AND
HEAT IMPROVE MOBILITY AND THE
REASON WHY I SAY IS THAT AND
THESE ARE NOT PRESCRIPTIVE IS
BECAUSE WHERE. THESE PROJECTS
HAPPEN ON HOW THEY LOOK REALLY
NEEDS TO BE INFORMED BY A
COMMUNITY DE SIGNED LET.
PROCESS.
I'M AND THEN FINALLY THE REQUEST
THAT WE HAVE FOR THE STATE.
.
WE WANT TO SEE A TRUE COMMIT ON
TRUE COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WE WANT THE STATE TO
DEVELOP A PUBLIC HEALTH PROJECTS
THAT ARE IN PROXIMITY TO THE
DISADVANTAGED POPULATIONS.
AND THAT THESE PROJECTS GO
BEYOND US MITIGATION.
I'M WE WOULD LIKE OF FOR THE
PURPOSES OF HAVING MEANINGFUL
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT THAT THE
TEN YEAR PLAN IDENTIFIES THE KEY
DECISION POINTS IN WHICH
COMMUNITY INPUT. WILL SERVE A
PURPOSE
WE.
AGAIN AS I STATED EARLIER
HAVING RECEIVING JUST
INFORMATION DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
THAT ON PURPOSE OF THE
INFORMATION SPUR SENATE ASSET
THAT STUNNED.
PHONE.
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL.
POINTS FOR PROPOSALS IN THE RFP
PROCESS THAT INCLUDE A
COMMUNITY.
ENGAGEMENT DE SIGNED PROCESS.
VALUE IT EARLIER WE HEARD THAT
THERE MIGHT NOT BE BIDDING THERE
MIGHT BE A DESIGN BUILD PROCESS.
WHICHEVER ONE IT IS.
I THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
COMMUNITY TO SIGN AND GET THEM
INVOLVED IN IT AND PROJECTS
WOULD DO THAT TO RECEIVE MORE
POINTS.
.
WE WOULD LIKE TO DEVELOP.
WE WOULD LIKE FOR THE STATE TO
DEVELOP A LONG TERM PROCESS FOR
SEEKING SOLUTIONS TO THE SALTON
SEA. NOT INCLUDE THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AS KEY STAKEHOLDERS
AND.
I WILL LEAVE YOU OR OFFER A TWO
TOOLS THAT CAN GET US WHO MORE
AUTHENTIC ON COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND THAT IS
PARTICIPATORY BUDGETING I KNOW
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HANS I MEAN
IF THE BOND PASSES. ON THEIR
SOME MONEY EVEN THAT'S GOING TO
BE ALLOCATED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
COULD THERE BE A. PARTICIPATORY
BUDGETING SO THAT THE COMMUNITY
CAN DECIDE HOW THOSE DOLLARS
SHOULD BE SPENT AND WHERE.
ON AND THE OTHER ONE WHICH I'VE
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES.
DISTANT FOR IT'S AN ON GOING
NOTICES HAVING COMMUNITY LET
DECENT.
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF THE
PRESENTATIONS AYE I'LL START
WITH.
THE DOCTORS.
COMMENTS. YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
A REMINDER.
OF THE STATE OF EMERGENCY THAT
THAT. THIS PROBLEM PRESENTS.
AND.
IT IS IN BY.
COINCIDENCE THAT THAT.
YOU WRAP UP THIS HEARING WITH
REMIND YOU KNOWS EXACTLY
WHAT IS AT STAKE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. SO WE WENT THROUGH THE
SECOND PANEL AND WE GOT A GOOD.
OVERVIEW OF WHAT'S HAPPENING OR
NOT HAPPENING IN WHERE YOU KNOW.
EFFORTS ARE BEING MADE TO GET ON
TRACK.
TO GETTING THESE PROJECTS UNDER
WAY.
BUT HAVING YOU ALL PRESENT YEAR
THE LOCAL PERSPECTIVE I THINK IS
EXTREMELY. A THE WAY THAT THIS
CONVERSATION ALWAYS NEEDS TO
START AND AND. IS THAT THERE ARE
REAL PEOPLE WITH REAL. DANGERS
BEFORE THEM.
AS THE.
IT HAS BEEN PRESENTED YOU KNOW
THERE'S COMMUNITIES WITH CLOSE
AT THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
RESIDE. IN THAT AREA I I DON'T
WANT TO.
YOU KNOW.
TAKE AWAY FROM THE INCREMENTAL
PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN MADE.
WITHOUT QUESTION PUTTING
TOGETHER THE PLAN BY THE LOCALS
COMING TOGETHER.
A FUNDING ALLOCATION OF EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TWO YEARS AGO
AND NOW THE POTENTIAL OF HAVING
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BUT
YOU KNOW TO ME THAT'S LIKE.
CELEBRATING THAT THE DODGERS
MADE IT TO THE WORLD SERIES IT.
BUT THEN IT WENT.
RIGHT.
AND WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE YET AS
IT RELATES TO WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN.
WITH THE SALTON SEA
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PLAN. UP
DOCTOR YOU YOU MENTIONED
SOMETHING AND I JUST WANTED TO
GET A CONFIRMATION IF I IF I
WROTE THIS DOWN CORRECTLY.
AS YOU SAID THE SEVENTY PERCENT
OF THE DUST.
PROBLEMS IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY ORIGINATE FROM THE
EXPOSED SOIL SURROUNDING THE
SULTAN T. IS THAT.
RIGHT THERE THE PAPER LAST YEAR
THAT SOME SOME OF THE COMPONENTS
OF THE DUST
I'M YOU CAN ACTUALLY DETERMINE
WHETHER IT'S SAFE FROM DESERT
SOILS THAT SORT OF THING. AND
THE ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT SET UP
TO SEVENTY PERCENT IS COMING
DIRECTLY FROM THE EXPOS PLY.
BETTER.
THE A NUMBER THAT I THINK.
.
I'VE NOT HEARD BEFORE.
NEARLYTOUCHED ON THE POPE
PULMONARY CARDIOVASCULAR. A
DISEASE PROBLEMS PERCENTAGES THE
CAUSES OF SPECIFIC.
YOU KNOW MORAL YOU KNOW
OUTCOMES AS A RESULT OF NEO
CERTAIN AND ACTIVITIES GOING ON.
YOU MENTIONED THE RESPIRATORY
DISEASE STATISTICS AMONGST
CHILDREN IN THE REGION BUT
THAT'S NOT A A STATISTIC THAT I
HAVE HEARD BEFORE. CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE TO
HIGHLIGHT AS THE.
EXPOSURE OF THE PLAYA CONTINUES
TO GROW RIGHT CLEARLY THAT
NUMBER WILL CONTINUE TO AFFECT.
THE AIR QUALITY IN THE REGION
AND THAT WITHOUT A DOUBT WE
KNOW.
THAT THAT WILL TRANSLATE INTO
GREATER PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEMS.
AND FOR SOME PEOPLE YOU KNOW
THEY LOOK AT THIS FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF THE ECONOMICS.%
BOTH TO THE HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE AS WELL AS
THE ECONOMIC VIBRANCY OF THE
REGION RIGHT AND SO WHICHEVER
WAY YOU LOOK AT IT THERE
CERTAINLY TREMENDOUS. IMPACT
THEIR. AYE YOU TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT.
DE DOES SUPPRESSION PROJECTS
WENT LIMP PROJECTS DESCRIBED.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS AFFECTING
IN YOUR OPINION I JUST BASED ON
PRESENTATIONS A RESEARCH THAT
YOU'VE DONE?
TO DECREASE THAT SEVENTY
PERCENT I MEAN I ARE THESE THE
PROJECTS THAT WILL. BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE.
I AIR QUALITY PROBLEMS THAT LEAD
TO THE SEVENTY PERCENT DUSTIN
THEM THAT WE'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS WITHIN THE BREED
CENTER ON ON THE QUESTION I
THINK.
THERE ISN'T AN IN THE
MANAGEMENT PLAN THAT THERE ISN'T
A LOT OF DETAIL ON WHETHER OR
NOT. THESE.
DUST SUPPRESSION.
ACTIVITIES ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE EFFECTIVE AND I THINK
THAT'S ONE CONCERN BECAUSE THE
EXPOS PIE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
GROW.
SOME I WOULD ALSO.
MENTION THAT YOU KNOW WHERE
ALSO HAVING TO LOOK AT IT YOU
DON'T JUST HAVE TO LIVE BY THE
SHORES OF SOUND SEEM TO BE
AFFECTED
BECAUSE OF THE PARTICLE
TRANSPORT REALLY GOES THROUGHOUT
THE. COACHELLA VALLEY.
AND SO.
THAT IS A CONCERN NOT JUST
LOCALLY TOM TO THE DUST AT THE
AT THE PLAYA BUT ALSO EXTENDING
THROUGH THE.
VALLEY.
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS I THINK
THAT IS ALSO RELEVANT TO THINK
OF IN TERMS OF THE TOM
POPULATIONS THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE AFFECTED. MAIN BE SOMETHING
TO IT CAN THE CONSIDERATION
BEYOND JUST THE.
DUST AND THE DUST SUPPRESSION
BUT ALSO AT THE LEVEL OF WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE WHERE THEY WORK.
KIND OF TAKING AN ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT EXPOSURES AND WHAT RISKS WE
ARE ACTUALLY. NAM THAT.
SEEING AMONG THE COMMUNITIES I
THINK THAT MAYBE ANOTHER
PERSPECTIVE TO LOOK AT.
THANK YOU I I WANNA THAT GET
INTO THE COMMUNITY OUR REGION
GAUGE MEANT THAT CONVERSATION
WHICH OUR LAST PRESENTER.
TOUCHED ON. AN OUR SECOND
PRESENTER WHO IS TASKED WITH
SOME OF THAT.
A.
WHAT'S THE GAP THAT WE NEED TO
KIND OF FILL IN HERE BECAUSE.
ON ONE AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WE'RE DOING OUTREACH ENGAGEMENT.
IN THE COMMUNITY AND WE JUST
HEARD FROM OUR LAST PRESENTER
THAT THERE ISN'T ENOUGH GOING ON
NOT NOT JUST WITH THE.
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PLAN WHICH IS
THE I THINK THE FOCAL POINT OF
THE PRESENTATION. UP BUT IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING MOVING
FORWARD IT IS THERE A GAP THAT
NEEDS TO BE FILLED HERE CLEARLY
THAT'S MY TAKE WAY THAT THERE
IS.
THAT PERHAPS MR OLD METAL IS
THERE SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO.
BE DONE ON OF THE PART OF THAT
YOUR ROLE IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
COMMUNICATE WITHOUT REACH.
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
YEAH NO I A COMPLETELY AGREE A
THINK THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S NO
ONE SIZE FITS ALL YOU KNOW YOU
CAN GO OUT OF MICROSCALE WHERE
YOU'D. IMPLEMENTING
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AS STRATEGIES YELL OR REGIONAL
STRATEGIES I THINK THAT. WE NEED
TO YOU KNOW VISIT DAY EVERY
POSSIBLE. A TOOL THAT'S OUT
THERE HOW WE CAN REACH THE HIGH
REACH POPULATION SPAS THAT'S
WHAT WE DUBBED IT THE HARD TO
REACH POPULATIONS.
OF SOME OF THE REMEDIES CAN
OCCUR AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ME THE
IDEAL SITUATION WOULD BE THAT
FOR EVERY ACRE EXPOSE WE HAVE A
DOSE OF MITIGATION YOU KNOW FOR
THAT ACRE BUT IT'S NOT HAPPENING
AT THAT RATE. THE REALITY IS IS
THAT COMMUNITY WILL HELP WAS
ALREADY EXPOSED TO HIGH LEVELS
OF P. M. EVEN BEFORE THE SEA
BECAME. THE MAJOR PROBLEM I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THREE YEARS AGO WE
WERE FOCUS ON THE LOCAL
STRATEGIES DEALING WITH LOCAL
SOURCES DEALING WITH. PM COMING
FROM LOCAL INDUSTRY COMING FROM
DESERT OFFROAD COMING FROM
AGRICULTURE FROM MANY DIFFERENT
SOURCES NOW ATTENTION IS NOW
HAVING TO GO TO OUR MAJOR SOLIS
SEAVER DOT DRIVERS NOT TIME I
HEAR THAT SCARY NUMBER SEVENTY
PERCENT. IT DOES SEEM THAT JUST
YOU KNOW VISUALLY THOSE OF US
WHO LIVE THERE. COULD PROBABLY
SAY YEAH THAT'S DEATHLY SEEMS
ABOUT RIGHT. ARE.
IN TERMS OF OUR DEAN WHAT'S A
LARGER FIX THAT'S WHAT I THINK
TIME AND TIME AGAIN OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS I HAVE SAID
NATURAL RESOURCES. NEEDS TO
ADOPT PUBLIC HEALTH POLICIES
THEY NEED TO ADOPT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE POLICIES.
WE CANNOT REVERSE.
IN A HALF A CENTURY OF THIS
ENGAGEMENT FROM THE COMMUNITY.
THAT HAS NOT DELIBERATELY BEEN
ENGAGED ON THE SALTON SEA OUT
COMMUNITIES HAVE NOT
HISTORICALLY BEEN INVITED.
TO THE SALTON SEA REGION OTHER
THAN BE MADE AWARE LIKE STAY
AWAY FROM YOU KNOW THE DRAINAGE
RAVER STAY AWAY FROM. THE SALTON
SEE THAT WE DON'T HAVE A CULTURE
OF APPRECIATING UNTIL MOST
RECENTLY THE HABITAT THE
WILDLIFE. OTHER THINGS IN AND
OTHER ARTICLE ARTICLE TREASURES
THAT EXIST IN THAT AREA. YES I%
THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
INCREASE OF RESOURCES THE BOTTOM
THE NORSE INSIGHT ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ON HEALTH
AS WELL AS THE SOUTHERN SIDE AND
THERE ARE OTHERS CONTRIBUTORS
ARE OUT THERE. SAYING YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO INVEST
YOU KNOW THERE'S HEALTH
CONVINCED TO SAY WE WANT INVEST
ANNOUNCEMENT EVENTUALLY ONE
INVEST ON SCHOOL FLAT PROGRAMS
WE WANT AND BASS I'M MORE%
MONITORING. YOU KNOW AND THIS
CAN BE DONE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
SEA ENGAGEMENT IS A MAJOR GOAL
IS FOR THE COMMUNITY BEING
GAUGE.
BUT TO REVERSED YOU KNOW HALF A
CENTURY OR MORE OF THIS
ENGAGEMENT OR PERHAPS EVEN THE
LIBERAL IT. LACK OF ENGAGEMENT
IT'S IT'S NOT GONNA BE A YOU
KNOW SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA BE
SOLVED OVERNIGHT IT'S GONNA BE.
A IS THAT WE NEED TO MULTIPLY
THE AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT THAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S GOING TO YIELD
POSITIVE OUTCOMES BUT IS NOT THE
OVER A FIX IT'S A TEMPORARY FIX
BECAUSE WE NEED TO MITIGATE. THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE WILL BE EXPOSED
THAT WE DON'T HAVE AN ACRE
DOSAGE OF MITIGATION FRED READ
ACRE EXPOSE SO EIGHT EIGHT IT
AGE A SHORT TERM AND
INTERMEDIATE SOLUTION IS. GET
THE INFORMATION OUT GET PEOPLE
TO HAVE CONTROL OF HOW THEY MAKE
ARE. HOW THEY?
?
I ADJUSTED DAILY ACTIVITIES TO
REDUCE EXPOSURE TO THESE
HAZARDOUS
CONTAMINANTS
RIGHTS OUTSIDE WOULD SAY THAT
YES WE NEED TO CONTINUE THESE
EFFORTS ON THE SOUTHERN END ON
AN ANNOUNCEMENT AND. ARE
CONTINUE TO INVEST AND ON THESE
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
AND. AND DAHLE A SOVIET PAST YOU
KNOW CLEARLY HAS A ROADMAP OF
HOW THAT COULD HAPPEN. OGDEN
THERE'S OTHERS YOU KNOW THAT
THAT CLEARLY HAVE A LOT OF THOSE
AND WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE BRING
THOSE FOR. MY QUESTION WHAT WHAT
DO YOU NEED FROM THE GROUP
THAT'S TASKED WITH E. COMMITTING
GAVE AN OUTREACH OF ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SO AGAIN THE THINK
GAP.
I THINK IS THAT THERE IS NO
CLEAR POINTS FOR WHEN COMMUNITY
IMPLANT.
REALLY INFORMS THE STEPS MOVING
FORWARD THERE IS AND HAS BEEN.
FORUMS WHERE THE COMMUNITY
RECEIVES THE SAME INFORMATION
THAT YOU ARE RECEIVED FROM THE
STATE THIS IS THE MAP THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE DOING.
THAT IF INFORMATION
THAT IS NOT ENGAGEMENT.
SO WHAT WE HAVE ASKED THE STATE.
AND THE SALTON SEA TEAM THAT'S
INVOLVED WITHOUT REACHED ON IS
THAT THEY PROVIDE US WITH WHERE
ARE THOSE KEY MILESTONES ON
BUILDING HEALTHY COMMUNITIES IS
ALREADY ENGAGING COMMUNITY.
WE WANT TO BRING THEM TO THIS
MEETINGS BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S MEANINGFUL AND
I'M WE HAVE YET TO RECIEVE FOR
THOSE KEY MILESTONES.
WILL BE AND WHERE WE CAN TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL INPUT THE
OTHER.
GAP LIKE GUINNESS IN THE PLAN.
WE ARE A ON PROJECTS ARE BEING
LOCATED BASED ON IN THE CITY. IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT NINA NEXT TO
NORTH SHORE WEST CHOICE.
MECCA THAT THERE'S NO
EMISSIVITY IT JUST MEANS MAYBE
THAT THERE'S MORE IN SOME AREAS
THAN.
THAN IN OTHERS.
BUT WE'RE NOT PRIORITIZE SEEN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE RIGHT
NEXT TO THE SCENE EVEN THAT IF
THERE'S LOW EMISSIVITY ON THE
WEST OR THE EAST WHY ARE WE NOT
DOING ANYTHING THERE. BECAUSE
THERE'S MORE EMISSIVITY IN THE
SOUTH AND I MEAN I DON'T KNOW
HOW NEAR THE COMMUNITIES I'M NOT
AS FAMILIAR.
.
WITH HELP NEAR THE COMMUNITIES
ARE TO THE SEA BUT I KNOW THAT
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY WERE
LIVING RIGHT NEXT TO IT AND
THERE'S NOTHING BEING DONE.
MISTER ROSE TRAILER YOU HAVE.
.
HAVE BEEN GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE THE LEAD ON SOME
PROJECTS.
A AYE YOU SHARED A BIT ABOUT THE
A TORCH MARTINEZ PARTNERSHIP.
THE MAGNITUDE OF PROJECT ISN'T
ANYWHERE NEAR THE SCALE OF SOME
OF THE PROJECTS THAT WE WERE
DISCUSSING EARLIER BUT. CAN YOU
CAN YOU JUST STEP APPLY THE
SAME.
APPROACH METHODOLOGY
TWO PROJECTS SAME SIZE OR LARGER
AND THE REASON WHY I ASKED THE
QUESTION IS YOU KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO BE TASK WITH THAT A
CHUNK OF MONEY.
POTENTIALLY THE COMES FROM PROP
SIXTY EIGHT.
.
ARE THERE PLANS TO GONNA TAKE
THAT MONEY AND BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE STRATEGIES
THAT ARE PART OF THE MANAGEMENT
PLAN ALREADY. KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT IS OUR HOPE IS TO
TAKE WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED AT THE
SCALE OF COURSE MARTINEZ.
A WETLANDS PROJECT MANY OF THE
SAME.
KINDS OF PROCESS SEIZE THE
PERMITTING A PROCESS THESE ARE
THE SAME WHETHER IT'S A LARGE
PROJECT OR A A SMALLER PROJECT
SO THE THE THE SAME STEPS HAVE
TO BE TAKEN.
REGARDLESS OF SCALE IN IN MANY
INSTANCES SO WHAT. GOOD BEING
ABLE TO TAKE A PUT MORE OF A
PILOT SCALE LEARN FROM THAT AND
THEN EXPAND THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE WANT TO DO WITH THE SALT SEA
WE HAVE A. NEGOTIATIONS RIGHT
NOW TO DOUBLE THAT TOWARDS
MARTINEZ WETLANDS PROJECT WITH
FACE TO THAT'S A MINUTE THAT AS
WE SPEAK. DO WILL BEGIN THAT
EXPANSION THAT'S I SHOULD
CLARIFY THAT'S UNDER A THAT A
POT OF MONEY FROM PROPERTY FOR.
THIS WOULD NOT BE.
TAPPING INTO THAT EIGHTY
MILLION THOUGH UNDER PROP ONE OR
THAT PROP SIXTY EIGHT BUT OUR
EXPECTATION IS THAT.
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER OF.
.
S. C. H. IS THE CLOSEST PROJECT
THE STATE HAS TO ACTUALLY BEING.
THAT CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
CONSTRUCTED.
CLOSE ON THE HEELS OF THAT IS A
PROJECT CONCEDE THAT THE NORTH
AND NORTH LAKE WHICH WOULD BUILD
INTO A LARGER. ABOUT.
PERIMETER LIKE POTENTIALLY
AROUND THE EDGES OF THE SEA THAT
WOULD ADDRESS OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT TO MY
COLLEAGUES AWAY POSIT MENTION.
SO OUR INTENT IS TO EXAMINE.
PROJECTS IN THAT AREA THAT WE
CONCEIVED TO BE NEXT IN LINE
FOR.
IMPLEMENTATION AS FELLOW BRUCE
WILCOX MENTION THERE IS A TASK
ORDER THAT IS.
HAS BEEN. RELEASED TO DO
FURTHER DEFINE THAT PROJECTS
WOULD CONFORM TO THE STATE
CRITERIA. BUT IT ALSO WILL MEET
ADDITIONAL OF MULTIPLE DELIVERED
BENEFITS OR LOOKING FOR IN TERMS
OF RECREATION ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY WE THINK WE CAN DO
ALL OF THOSE. IF WE INTEGRATE
THOSE MULTIPLE BENEFITS IN A WAY
THAT CREATES DEEPWATER HABITAT.
YOU WON'T FIND ANYWHERE ELSE
AROUND THE CITY TO HIGH PRIORITY
WE'VE GOT TO GET THAT DONE. AS
WELL AS PROTECTING THE
COMMUNITIES AND PERHAPS BUILDING
SOME ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THAT
CREATES A FINANCIAL TO WE
WOULDN'T HAVE OTHERWISE I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORK IN A CLOSELY
WITH MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY I.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT STRATEGY.
THAT THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THE.
TO SOME EXTENT YEAR THAT SAYS
SEEMS TO BE A MISSING PIECE.
MOVING FORWARD.
AB
MY COLLEAGUES ARE ARE CORRECTED
THERE HAS BEEN MORE OF A TOP
DOWN APPROACH AND IF BEN PROJECT
FOCUSED.
OF THE STATE HAS FOCUSED ON
EXPLAINING HIS TEN YEAR PLAN TO
THE PUBLIC.
AND.
I THINK THE.
THE STATE HAS BEEN A FORTHRIGHT
IN AND ACKNOWLEDGING THIS IS
PROBABLY NOT THE IDEAL WAY TO
APPROACH THIS.
AND THEY MADE ADJUSTMENTS THEY
HAVE ACCOMMODATED.
UNDER MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION CHANGING THE NAME OF
THAT.
PARTICULAR ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FROM OUTREACH COMMITTEE TO
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT COMMITTEE.
I THINK THAT'S AN INDICATION OF
THAT CHANGING STANCE AND FOCUS
THAT.
I THINK IS IT BEING
ACKNOWLEDGED AND LARGELY TO THE.
OF SUGGESTIONS OF OF OUR
CULTURE TO STABLE MY HOPE IS
THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT.
THERE ARE SOME SCHEDULED.
A ACTIVITIES THAT TO BEGIN A
MUCH MORE THOROUGH ENGAGEMENT
YOU KNOW COMING FORWARD AND.
THE BENCHMARKS THAT NEED TO BE
SAID ALONG WITH THE TIME LINES
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT ON THE
PREVIOUS.
A PANEL.
UP CAN YOU TOUCH A LITTLE BIT ON
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S COMPLY
I KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITIES OF FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES THERE. ARE I THINK
THAT WAS AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND THAT. THAT WAS
RAISED EARLY ON WITH THE LA
OFFICE AND MAYBE YOU CAN KIND OF
FAMOUS A PICTURE OF ONE OF THE
ACTION STEPS THAT WE NEED TO BE
PURSUING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IT IT
DID BEARS MENTIONED THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OWNS ABOUT
FORTY PERCENT OF THE REAL ESTATE
IN AROUND THE CITY.
THEY HAVE SIGNED A AND M. O. U.
WITH THE SALT SEA AUTHORITY THIS
IS THE PART OF A TERROR ATTACK
ABOUT.
AS WELL AS A OF THE VERY SIMILAR
AMMO YOU WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT RESOURCES
AGENCY.
.
THEY PLEDGE TO COOPERATE.
IN AND SHARE INFORMATION AND
HAVE MORE OF A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH
AN INTER AGENCY. COOPERATIVE
WE HAVE YET TO SEE ANY OF THE
AGENCIES TAKE LEAD ON THAT.
THEY HAVE NOT ALL ALSO OF MY
COLLEAGUE BRUCE WILCOX MENTION
THEY HAVE NOT YET BEEN.
ABLE TO LIVE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS NOT COMMITTED TO
FUNDING THAT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR COMMITMENT AND THE AMMO
YOU FOR A LONG TERM.
O. THEY'LL.
BUT WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE AT
LEAST ON IN THE SHORT TERM AS A.
.
A LEADERSHIP ROLE FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
DEPARTMENT INTERIOR SEEMS TO
MAKE SENSE AND PERHAPS OF BARACK
IMATION SINCE THEY OWN A LOT OF
THE LAND AROUND THERE AND THEY
ARE ENGAGED. WOULD BE ONE OF
THOSE AGENCIES THAT WE THINK
COULD BRING TOGETHER THE FEDERAL
FAMILY AND THEY COULD SERVE AS
POINT.
TO HAVE MORE OF IT INTEGRATED
FEDERAL WORK GROUP
THAT CAN THEN WORK WHAT THE
STATE AND LOCALS THAT WOULD HELP
SPEED THINGS UP WE THINK THAT'S
ONE WAY WE CAN GAIN. OF SOME AT
GROUND ON AT AND SOME.
RECOVER SOME LOST TIME EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY SIMPLY HAVING THAT LEVEL
COOPERATION CAN HELP EXPEDITE
PERMITTING PROCESS SEES AND CAN
HELP COORDINATE. THE KIND OF
FEDERAL PLANNING THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
OF THAT.
ON THE FUNDING SIDE.
STATE AND COOPERATE WITH THE
SOLVE SEE AUTHORITY HAS EXAMINED
POTS OF MONEY. THAT MAY BE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE.
IN ORDER TO SPEND THAT MONEY.
THE.
APART RAG REQUIRES A NEW.
FEASIBILITY PLAN FOR OUR
WATERSHED.
AND.
.
THE SAME KIND OF REQUIREMENT IS
SO EXPECTED FROM THE ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS.
BY THE WAY THE SALT SEA THOR
<c.green> AS IS IDENTIFIED AS
THE</c>
PREFERRED NOT FEDERAL PARTNER.
FLORA CONTRACT WITH THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS IN THE WATER
RESOURCES DEVELOPMENT ACT.
POLLS. ARMY CORPS AND USDA AND
CONCEIVABLY <c.green> PI.
HAVE</c>
SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS FOR A
FEASIBILITY STUDY ON WATERSHED
SCALE. WHAT SHOULD WE DO THREE
OF THESE?
EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING STUDIES
ONE WE THANK ONE SHOULD SUFFICE
AND WE HAVE A BLUEPRINT ALREADY
ON THE GROUND.
WE THINK THE SALT SEA MANAGER
PLAN SERVES AS A BASIS FOR THAT.
THAT'S A AREA WHERE WE COULD
SAVE A LOT OF TIME A LOT OF
MONEY AND IF WE HAVE A
CONSOLIDATED INTEGRATED
APPROACH.
WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
ACKNOWLEDGE?
AND INCORPORATE THE SALTY MANTRA
PLANET WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN FROM
WATERSHED FEASIBILITY PIECE.
NOW WE'VE GAINED SOME TIME WE'VE
SAVED A LOT OF MONEY AND WE'VE
ALSO ESTABLISHED A WAY TO BRING
DOWN FEDERAL MONEY.
THAT THE ARMY CORPS AT THE USDA.
AT EPA THAT CAN REINFORCE
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IT THE STATE
AND THE LOCAL LEVELS AND NOW WE
HAVE A PLAN. THAT ACTUALLY WORKS
FOR EVERYBODY.
MAKE YOUR GOING TO WRITTEN DOWN
SOME OF THE STEPS I KNOW THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TOGETHER.
IN THE COMING. WEEKS WITH OUR
OWN CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE.
AND DE. TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THIS IN A BLUE PRINTER MAP THAT
YOU
SPOKEN UP.
SO THAT COLLECTIVELY RIGHT THAT
SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT OUR
LOCAL.
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVE IN
THE EFFORTS IN WASHINGTON DC AS
AS A STATE DELEGATION. ARM TO
REALLY HOLD.
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND THOSE
AGENCIES LAMAR COUNTABLE.
TO TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR
WHAT IS THAT FORTY PERCENT IF WE
CAN CALL IT YOU KNOW A PART OF
THAT RESPONSIBILITY THAT THEY
HAVE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU OF BOARDMAN
MEMORY BY MY VET TO CHECK THINGS
LOOKS APOLOGIZE FIRST BEGAN TO
TURN HERE BUT. I THINK IT WOULD
BE ROOM HAS CITED MENTIONED BUT
THEY'RE JUST THREE CRAIG
ELEMENTS I THINK THEY'RE
IMPORTANT. AND ONE IS THAT
RESEARCH PRIOR TO THE LAST.
FIGHTERS WOULD SAY I DID NOT
HAVE A STRONG COMPONENT
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION AND I
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S HAS CHANGED
SIGNIFICANTLY. ARE THE OTHER IS
THAT DE CALL WE.
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION AND
ENGAGEMENT PROJECT THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER HAT.
I A COMMUNITY ADVISORY THAT
HELPED DEVELOP. THAT AND I
BELIEVE THAT ANY FUTURE
EDUCATION ENGAGEMENT TYPE OF
PROJECTS.
ARE AND I THINK THAT SUPPORTS
WHAT FLEW PAST. HAS A STRONG
ELEMENT
I IN AND BELIEVE THAT THAT THE
OF THE FISCAL. OUR CONVERSATION
ALSO WAS BROUGHT ABOUT I THINK
THAT'S KEY AND THIRD WHICH IS
THE MOST CRITICAL OF AYE. IF THE
QUESTION WAS ASKED WHAT HAVE WE
SEEN THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
ENGAGEMENT IT'S IN THE YOUTH
ENGAGEMENT AND WE'VE BEEN
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BRING THESE
YOUTH. ADHERE TO THE TO THE TO
THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE MET WOULD
SEND A MOTHER THAT SHE IS WAS.
THEN DAWN BUT THE YOUTH
ENGAGEMENT THE ENGAGEMENT THAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE SCHOOLS I WOULD
SAY IS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT MOST
PROMISING ENGAGEMENT THAT WE
HAVE SEEN. BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
STUDENTS WHO CAME OUT HERE SLIM
BACK IN ST I'M SURE THAT.
POLITICS IS WHAT I WANT TO
PURSUE I'M SURE THAT SCIENCE AND
AND AND AND ANOTHER.
ACADEMIC TYPES OF.
OF CAREER GOALS IS THAT THEY
WANT TO PURSUE SERGEANT
EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT. DO YOU
THINK AGE MEN ENVIRONMENT
LITERACY CIVIC LITERACY AT
SCHOOL LEVEL AT THE HIGH SCHOOLS
HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS AND IT'S
BEEN YIELDING SIGNIFICANT. OF.
.
THE PROGRESS IN OUR REGION.
THANK YOU SO MATTER ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU TO ALL THE PRESENTERS
HAVE BOTH YOURSELF THAT THOSE ON
PANEL TO.
I THINK THAT WE CAN COME TO
CONCLUDE HERE WE WILL HAVE SOME
PUBLIC COMMENTS BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY I THINK A COUPLE OF TAKE
AWAYS IS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
GET.
SOME.
ACTION PLAN HAVE
BY JUNE.
TO HIGHLIGHT HOW WE GET BACK ON
TRACK.
TO MEETING THE OBJECTIVES OF THE
MANAGEMENT PLAN. OH WE HEARD THE
DEPARTMENT SAY THAT BY DECEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS WHEN WE
WILL.
.
VERY LIKELY BEGIN THE.
S. THE C. H. PROJECT RIGHT THE
A SPECIES CONSERVATION HABITAT
PROJECT.
AND THAT.
WE ARE VERY CLOSE
TO ADDRESSING THE EASEMENT
ISSUES.
THAT HAVE BEEN HOLDING UP THE
BEGINNING OF THAT.
WE.
HIGHLIGHTED THE ISSUES OF.
ONGOING.
INCREASE OF STAFFING AND
CAPACITY THAT YOU KNOW WE
BELIEVE COULD POTENTIALLY HELP
MOVE.
THESE.
PROJECTS AND PROCESS FORWARD.
AND THEN LASTLY YOU KNOW I I
HIGHLIGHTED IN I I CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT FOLKS.
WOULD DISAGREE THAT WE WANT THIS
PROJECT.
TO RISE TO THE LEVEL LOVE
PRIORITY AND IMPORTANCE AS A
PROJECT LIKE THE OROVILLE DAM
PROJECT AND HOW WE RESPONDED TO
THAT EMERGENCY. CONSIDERING THE.
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPLICATIONS THAT
WE HEARD DOCTOR.
LOW EXPLAIN TO US.
ARE YOU.
A CRITICAL AND SO I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
AND HOPE THAT THE YOU TO WALK
AWAY WITH SOME OF THESE TAKE
AWAYS AND FOLLOW UPS THAT WILL
TAKE PLACE. OUR STAFF WILL BE
ENGAGE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY.
AS I MENTIONED I USED THE WORD
INTIMATELY.
YOU KNOW FOLLOWING EXACTLY THE
PROGRESS OR LACK OF. AND DATA AT
THE SAME TIME BEGIN SCHEDULING.
A YEAH HEARING OF THIS SORT IN
THE DISTRICT SO THAT OUR
COMMUNITY FOLKS CAN PARTICIPATE
DIRECTLY NOT VIA FACEBOOK OR NOT
VIA A STREAMLINED SESSION I
THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR. FROM THEM AS WELL.
NSULT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATINGWE APPRECIATE THAT
YOU.
PROVIDING TESTIMONY TODAY AND
THOSE WHO ARE HERE.
WITNESS SCENE I WILL NOW OPEN
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD AYE IF
YOU WOULD DUH PLEASE BE SO KIND
AS TO.
.
GET THE UP PUBLIC COMMENT SAID
GOING IN.
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO NAME OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OF JUST A VERY
BRIEF AS WE HAVE OTHER FOLKS
THAT ARE NEEDING TO USE THIS
ROOM VERY SOON. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
MIKE LINES OF THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY FOR OUT OF ON CALIFORNIA
WHICH HAS BEEN ENGAGED THE
SALTON SEA FOR MANY YEARS. I FOR
FIVE THANK YOU FOR THE OVERSIGHT
HEARING I THINK WE LEARNED A LOT
OF USEFUL INFORMATION AND
HOPEFULLY GET SOME PROGRESS TO
GO FORWARD.
.
I THINK. HAD THE SUPERION
FRANKLY IS YEAH.
EMPHASIZE A DEGREE OF
FRUSTRATION I THINK AND AND
MAYBE ADDED SOME OF THAT
FRUSTRATION TODAY I THINK
EVERYBODY WORKING ON THIS IS
WORKING HARD BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A BETTER
PROGRAM PUT IN PLACE MY HOPE IS
THAT THIS CAN BE ELEVATED NOT
ONLY THE LEGISLATURE. BUT FOR
THE INCOMING GOVERNOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT PERSON KNOWS THAT
THIS IS A PRIORITY AND THAT WE
GET A SECURE A PROMISE FROM THAT
PERSON IF THEY WILL ELEVATED AND
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S ADEQUATELY
STAFFED AS WELL AS ADEQUATELY
FUNDED.
I DO ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE BEEN HEARING FOR YEARS THE
PROMISES OF PROGRESS AND SO
WHILE I.
ADMIRE EVERYBODY THAT SPOKE
TODAY
THE PROMISE THAT WE WILL SEE A
PROJECTS START IN DECEMBER.
CONTINUES TO RING HOLLOW
SPEECHES CONSERVATION HABITAT
HAS BEEN UNDER DEVELOPMENT FOR
EIGHT YEARS RED HILL BAY
SOMETHING LIKE SIX YEARS
ANNOUNCED THE FEDERAL PROJECT
THE TORCH MARTINEZ PROJECT I
THINK IT'S WORTHY TO POINT OUT
HAS MADE SOME REALLY GREAT
PROGRESS AND I THINK A LOT OF
PREDICADORES AUNTIE OF. THORNY
FOR MAKING THAT HAPPEN MANY
CONTINUED SUPPORT TO MAKE SHORT
SUCCESSFUL BUT I THINK THE
PROMISED NOTHING HAPPENS OF THE
SALTON SEA AND TELL IT'S
ACTUALLY DONE.
AND THE LAST POINT I WANT TO
MAKE ON THE DELAYS.
IS REALLY THAT WHILE I'M HOPING
THAT THESE ISSUES WITH THE
EASEMENT WILL WILL SET SOME
PRECEDENTS LITTLE PAVE THE WAY
FOR FUTURE PROJECTS. I THINK WE
SHOULD ANTICIPATE AND EXPECT
ADDITIONAL DELAYS ON A PROJECT
BY PROJECT BASIS AND THE ONLY
WAY THAT GETS DEALT WITH IS
MAKING SURE THAT BRUCE AND WHO'S
EVER IN CHARGE OF THE PROJECT
HAS AN ADEQUATE STAFF THAT THEY
CAN TELL TO ATTENDED A PROGRAM.
AND THERE ARE CERTAIN
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CONSEQUENCES
IF IT'S NOT.
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS WEATHERS.
I USED TO MAKE SURE REAL
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE TO
PROTECT THE COMMUNITIES TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CAN
DELFINO THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM
DIRECTOR DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
AND I THINK THAT.
MIKE LINES IS PROBABLY VERY.
ADEPTLY ADEPTLY EXPRESSED
PROLLY THE.
THANK THANKFULNESS FOR HAVING
THE HEARING BUT ALSO SOME OF THE
FRUSTRATION WITH SOME OF THE
RESPONSES THAT WE HAD IN A AND
ALSO BE THANKFUL FOR THE
QUESTIONS THAT FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS RIGHT. SOLDIERS MAKE
THIS QUICKLY.
I THINK THAT.
YOU'VE ADDED YOU'VE POINTED OUT
I THINK IT'S RIGHT.
THE NEXT ACTION PLAN WHICH BY
THE WAY WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF PLAN
SO KIND OF ONE OF YOU TO THAT
PROGRESS THE ACTUAL PROJECT PART
BUT THE NEXT PLAN THAT YOU SEE.
AT THE END OF JUNE I THINK NEEDS
TO VERY CLEARLY HAVE TO HAVE. A
MORE DETAILED EXPLANATION ON IF
THERE'S ANY FURTHER ISSUES WITH
RESPECT TO EASEMENTS.
ANY PERMUTATIONS IN THOSE
ISSUES THAT THEY MIGHT SEE AND
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO STAFF THAT.
ON IN THE FUTURE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH DESIGN BUILD.
SOMETHING THAT HAD AUTHORITY
FOR FRANKLY FOR TWO YEARS AND
THE FACT THAT THEY JUST HAVE
SOMEONE STAFFED ON THE LAST
THREE WEEKS THAT'S LOOKING AT
THIS ISSUE AND HOW THEY'RE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT.
THE STAFFING AND RE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING AND RESOURCES THAT
FINALLY.
THERE WAS SOME OF THROUGH TOUGH
QUESTIONING I THINK FROM BOTH
YOU AND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO ON THE
FACT THAT THEY NEED ADDITIONAL
STAFFING WHERE DID THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL STAFFING AND WHAT IF
THEY NEED TO DO IN TERMS OF
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE TO MAKE
THIS WORK BETTER AND HAVE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
.
A ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS AND I
THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE IN THEIR
NEXT REPORT AND ALSO A SPECIFIC
TIMELINE. AND.
OUTCOMES.
IT IT'S A GAP CHART PERHAPS OF
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING
WITH RESPECT TO EACH ONE OF THE
PROJECT THAT THEY'VE LISTED
BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD THESE
PROJECTS IT THERE'S BEEN A
COUPLE NEW ONES THAT WERE ADDED
BUT.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
I THINK MISTER LINES MADE AN
EXCELLENT POINT IN THAT.
WE'VE ALWAYS WE'VE BEEN TOLD
CONSISTENTLY. NEXT JUNE NEXT
DECEMBER WILL BREAK GROUND NEXT
WHENEVER AND IT HAS NOT YET
HAPPENED AND I THINK THEY NEED
TO ARE REALLY CLEARLY SPELL OUT
A TIMELINE AND WHAT IT IS THAT
THEY NEED TO BE DOING. TO MEET
THAT TIMELINE THAT THEY'RE
SETTING OUT AND IF THERE'S
ENOUGH THERE ISN'T AN ABILITY TO
MEET THEIR TIMELINE.
YOU KNOW IN THE TIME THAT THEY.
YEP OF FOR TODAY HOW WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO DO ABOUT THAT.
SO AND IF THAT'S NOT IN THE OF
PLAN THAT YOU GET ON AT THE END
OF JUNE THEN THAT'S THOSE SHOULD
BE THE TOPIC THAT YOU RAISE IN
THE HEARING. ON THAT YOU HAVE
DOWN IN THE.
IN THE SONGS THE AREA WHICH ARE
VERY THANKFUL THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY
GAUGES AND I GUESS THAT THE THE
OTHER THING I WOULD ADD. TO
THEIR STAFFING AND IS WHAT ARE
THEY DOING ABOUT INCREASE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THE STAFFING TO DO IT
WHAT'D THEY NEED IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT INCREASE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. AND HOW
COULD THEY POTENTIALLY PARTNER
WITH OTHERS LIKE THE FOLKS THAT
YOU HAD HERE ON THIS LAST PANEL
TO MAYBE EXPAND THAT COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT.
SO THAT WOULD BE MY
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN.
MY NAME'S INTER FOLLAND I I'M
WITH THAT I'M SENIOR PROGRAM
OFFICER FOR THE WATER
FOUNDATION.
WE SPONSORED LAST YEAR'S YOU'LL
RECALL A TOUR OF THE SALTON SEA
AMONG FOLKS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE. AND.
WE ARE REPRESENTS A LARGER
COLLABORATION AND PHILANTHROPIES
A AROUND THE STATE THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND SOLVE. THESE REALLY
DAUNTING PROBLEMS.
I'D I JUST WANTED TO MAKE GUY
OF ONE REMARK. ABOUT AND AFTER
IT THAT WE'VE UNDERTAKEN TO ON
ANALYSTS AT OUTSIDE SUPPORT FROM
A CONSULTING FIRM TO TO TRY TO.
REALLY TACKLE THIS CHALLENGE OF
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE AND.
AND GOVERNANCE AND WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO GO OUT WITH A SONG AND
SEE PROGRAM THAT HAS. RIGHT NOW
MONEY OR A PLAN OF ACTION SOME
ORDERS ON AND AND CERTAINLY A
GREAT DEAL OF ENTHUSIASM.
FROM FROM THE PUBLIC QUE TO
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM BUT BUT IS
REALLY LACKING IN TERMS OF OUR
SUFFICIENT GOVERNANCE AND
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE. SO WE'RE
REALLY WE'VE INVESTED.
AYE AYE ECONOMIC SYSTEMS.
.
EH ECONOMIC GOOD AND PLANNING
SYSTEMS TO UNDERTAKE THAT
RESEARCH AND AND TWO. AND TO
REACH OUT TO STAKEHOLDERS BUT
ALSO TO EVALUATE AND LOOK AT
PROGRAMS. AND THAT YOU KEEP
REFERENCING THAT THE.
THAT WERE OF OF.
PROJECT IN THE PROGRAM AROUND
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AT
PROGRAMS FROM AROUND THE STATE
BUT ALSO AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT ACTUALLY
MOVING PROJECTS.
FORWARD QUICKLY AND WHAT DOES IT
TAKE TO DO THAT WHAT KIND OF
STRUCTURE DO WE NEED.
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT.
THAT THE WATER FOUNDATION AND
ITS ALLIES ARE ARE OUT OF
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING IN
DELIVERING ON BY JUNE.
TO INFORM YOUR THOUGHT THINKING
ON ALL OF THIS IS WELL AS THAT
OF AN EX GOVERNOR AND. AND SO
FORTH SO.
EXPERIMENTS.
GOOD MORNING CAO JOBS A CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA JUST WANTED TO ECHO
THE POINTS MADE BY MY CLIENTS
ABOUT ABOUT CONDUCTING OR
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE I THINK
TOMORROW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER OVERSIGHT HEARING AT
THAT WILL REALLY HIGHLIGHT WHERE
THE PRIORITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN.
AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT
THAT HAS BEEN THERE FOCUSING ON
THAT AT THE EXPENSE OF OTHER AYE
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
REALLY NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN
THE STATE FOR FOR PEOPLE AND
FOR.
A SPECIES AND SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN RELIGIOUS UNDERSCORE MAKING
AT THIS PARTY FOR THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION
I CAN'T THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING AMELAND ON THIS
WITH THE COMIC AS HE COULD LIE
YOU. THINK YOU TRIMMING IS HERE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
HAS RUN OUT THANK YOU FOR FOR
HAVING OF THESE HEARING TODAY.
AND ASKING.
AGENCIES TO A HAVE THE TANGIBLE
EVIDENCE OF WHAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE PROGRESS THAT'S
BEING MADE ON SOUND SEE.
AND I JUST WANNA.
COMMENT THAT. IT IS SELF BRING
POINTS A CONTINUUM.
OUR EFFORTS TOWARDS COMMITTEE
ENGAGEMENT COMMUNITY OUTREACH
ANNA I THINK IT IT'S IMPERATIVE
TO OUR.
TO ALL THE BATS OUT SOME.
SOME FUNDING TO THAT TO THAT
PURPOSE AND NOTHING FOR
EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BITTEN ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADDRESS COMMITTEE SEEN NONE. NO
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR
ATTENDING CLEARLY.
HIGH PRIORITY FOR US.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR WORK WITH THE EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATE TODAY LASTLY I KNOW
THE COMMENTS ARE MADE THAT THAT
THE NEXT GOVERNOR THE NEXT
GOVERNOR. QUITE FRANKLY I MEAN I
THINK THAT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BUT DOUBLE WORKING WITH THIS
GOVERNOR.
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME TO SEE SOME ZIP GOOD
PROGRESS BEING MADE PRIOR TO
THIS ADMINISTRATION GOING OUT
AND SO. I WOULD LIKE TO YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON TODAY AND
NOT TOMORROW.
VERSUS NEXT YEAR SO APPRECIATE
THAT THE COMMENTS THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR JOINING US. AND THAT
WE WILL MEET AGAIN THANK YOU
THIS MEANS OBJECT